the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
pieces are flying off the boards at the
super United rabbit and Blitz in Zagreb
Croatia try to keep up if you can but
these players calculations are fast and
their hands are even faster former world
champion Magnus Carlson has set the
field Ablaze winning all nine games
decimating everything in his path on his
way to clear first as predicted by
Magnus the world's number one rated
Blitz player alareza farugia went on a
tear racking up multiple wins to get
within Striking Distance of the leaders
Carlson sits alone at the top can he
continue to outpace the competition and
the clock only time will tell the final
day of Blitz Jess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
welcome back just fans to the final and
Championship date here at the super
United rapid and Blitz held him
beautiful Zagreb Croatia we start a day
in one of the most iconic Landmark City
squares here in the middle of Zagreb in
front of the Statue of Joseph yolacic
who was a great military leader well
who's going to be the best military
leader over the chessboard let's go to
the studio and find out
the grunge store returns to Croatia it
is rapid in Blitz action with the
greatest players in the world our live
coverage from the San Luis chess club
and Zagreb starts right now
hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us again I'm International
Master Nazi paikete and I'm here with my
brilliant co-host Grand Master yester
one Nasi wonderful are we witnessing the
greatest of all time what we saw
yesterday 9-0
his story has been made can he do it
again today I think that's what we're
all asking ourselves hello everyone and
Welcome to our show thank you for
joining us even as we witnessed it
yesterday it was amazing we were at a
loss for words Perfection what can you
say 9-0 each and every year the grand
chest organizers try to get the best
players in the world and nobody expected
the tournament to be adopted it's
extraordinary Nasi do the honors and
tell us about the standings let's take a
look we have Magnus Carlson leading the
tournament he has a three-point lead
it's incredible this Gap is just
superlative we lose words Sharon second
Fabiano caruana and yeah Ali Raza is
actually playing a very very good Blitz
tournament but he's four and a half
points behind it's extraordinary and uh
tell us about our format we have a 10
player around
the time control in Blitz is five plus
two there's a traditional scoring system
and no drawers allowed this of course is
our last day of broadcast so that is our
schedule and Miro what we and first of
all good to see you my friend what we
experienced yesterday was historic well
absolutely thank you yase my pleasure to
be here and you know we could
uh talk a lot about how many intrigues
there are it's a very close race for the
second well we are still looking at
lupulasco possibly winning his first
game and GCT points have to be split but
it's only one question on my mind you
know nine rounds
same opponents colors reversed can he do
it again the men of the tournament
Magnus Carlsen of course uh well fun
fact he is still not number one on world
Blitz rating well winning
29.6 ELO points but still well less than
10 points left to catch up with alireza
ferrugia who is world number one in
Blitz Fabiano caruana
all there in the top 10.
and yeah and Magnus Carlsen six times
World Blitz Champion once again
confirmed that yeah well he is the
greatest of all times Well nine out of
nine I'm lost for words and let's hear
from our colleagues in Zagreb who
managed to not only to witness but to
capture the very moment he wins his
ninth game Anastasia Christian
thanks uh Amira welcome back chess fans
to day five the championship day here in
Zagreb Croatia and what we witnessed
yesterday was historical legendary and
every other superlative that you can
find in the dictionary and uh let's take
a look at what transpired after that
last final move that secured Magnus nine
out of nine in day four
three two A2 and rook and he's nine for
nine nine out of nine right Magnus is
exultant
this is not the Magnus who was in in
shock in the Rapids when he lost back to
back games
thank you
and that's uh the scene that you
captured Anastasia yes I was in the
plane when you're at this moment when he
just won this game and the spectators
tried to upload but they couldn't do it
properly because the other game was just
played nearby and um you know Mike was
looked so happy now we will see how he
couldn't actually keep his emotions and
I will tell you Christian when you were
doing this interview with salireza
firoza Magnus was here nearby in the
play players area and he kept smiling
all the time all the way until he came
to the studio you can see here he says
are you not entertained
raising his hands up in here are you not
entertained I mean just an incredible
thing and the second time they started
applauding yes after the game was over
yes
was over at this moment so they were
uploading and now we can see this
amazing score absolutely incredible a
line score and everybody can remember
and will remember this is going to be in
the history history books 9 out of nine
and if you count the two rapid games
that he won in the previous day as well
that's 11 out of 11 and he has the
opportunity as you are mentioning mirror
to potentially continue his streak
what's going to happen here in Zagreb
while only time will tell so we're going
throw it back to St Louis as the games
are ready to start thank you Anastasia
thank you Christian and indeed do the
honors and tell us about the round 10
pairings Nazi let's take a look we have
Magnus Carlson starting the round with
Fabiano Corona let's call that our
Marquee matchup for the round 10. Rich
rapper will be playing good cash against
Anand that will be a wonderful backup
game in case we get a fizzle sorry
chicken sphere Russia and Duda play in
the pool they have been fighting very
hard what are they fighting for they're
fighting for a lot of money there's
total of 175 000 in prizes and the first
place winner is going to win 45 thousand
dollars second place thirty thousand
Thirty twenty five thousand a nice price
fund all the way down to Tenth the final
place of seven thousand I guess the
players are all fighting for second and
as far as those GCT points are concerned
I think 13 of them are going to
disappear into Magnus Carlson's account
but because he's the wild card it won't
matter at the final for the grand
Chester points and as we get ready for
the opening ceremony we do expect uh
some ceremonial first moves
from well illustrious guests you just
have to see
who shows up as we see Richie uh coming
in and playing at home
Richie I saw in miro's opening remarks
there he's actually gained some nice
rating points uh
Miro for this event thus far right and
while once again they say really report
is well of course very talented very
good player but not as stable right but
yeah I wish I could be unstable having
like good and bad results and still be
hovering around 27.50 you know
outstanding playing
absolutely and we're saying that the
alireza Ferocious having a very good
Blitz tournament indeed he comes into
the event as the world's number one
he gains a fraction of a rating point
for his day four performance and he
finds himself four and a half points
behind the leaders and he's playing like
he's the world's number one he's like
what's going on uh he's working up in
some parallel universe where he's being
overtaken as we see a young Christophe
Duda entered into playing Hall
no matter how well you play Magnus is
still playing better
we have this in chess online chess you
you play an opponent you play a lot of
Blitz games against one another and if
you win 10 in a row you adopted your
opponent well Magnus has won 11 in a row
he's adopted the tournament you need a
really big house
but the whole tournament comes and lives
with you
uh Miro again I I just I I I
reach in my mind for outstanding results
like this I remember
Yvonne Chuck Yvonne Chuck wanting a open
event with something like a 9-0 score I
think it was uh the
not the Barclays it
Lloyd's bank or something there was a
tournament in London where he did
outstanding but uh just watching it is
just it's amazing uh right yes I think
even well maybe it's a little bit you
know bold to state but when Robert
Fisher won at the U.S Championship was
perfect score right yep still we can
argue that the opposition wasn't as
tough not even close these are the
world's greatest players nobody will
argue that the U.S Championship
featured anywhere other than one player
in the top 10. Bobby
I have
um
I don't know if this is Marin marusich
yes yes the County Manager for super
United
oh sorry president of the organization
but you were so close
he nearly had it but on my sheet you're
right yeah is listed as the country
manager no he's the president and here
of course is Michael korsakovski the
executive director of the grand chess
tour Michael has uh served this function
I think from the very start of the
branches tour
Croatian professional tennis player
Amanda you know I could have guessed he
was a tennis player he looks like one
yeah
what do you think is the mindset
the madness might be at this moment he's
just won 11 games in a row
11. I can't even imagine right and now
he's playing Fabi who's world's number
four by Blitz right and who's been
world's number two uh for a number of
years in classic oops
and you're expecting to win
English and will we see E5 and
yeah remember in the rapid
um E4
they had that Knight A5 business right
that family did and Fabi won in the
Rapids
okay they're playing with it no remember
saying that that prep was from 2018. yes
exactly I I caught that too the world
championship match still using ideas
from that uh world championship match
yeah I heard that from Fabi that a lot
of the prep that goes into the world
championship match yeah it doesn't they
don't get to use it during the match
absolutely no just a fraction in fact of
what they what they had prepared so this
whole line with Bishop C5 really you
know it's an old line but it was
popularized this move Bishop C5 by
Alexander grishop early before that time
before grishek made Bishop C5 popular I
for example oh Bishop G2 had this
position numerous times as white
including against Michael tall and
everybody and I mean everybody made the
retreat Knight B6 and we continued from
here but Grisha made the move Bishop C5
popular and if you don't have to retreat
the Knight then well it makes perfect
sense Knight C4
does intimate I am prepared to play
Bishop takes C6 followed by Knight takes
E5 do something about it and that's why
we understand the move rookie eight by
Fabi and I think so far they're
following this game Carlson against
Wesley so from two years ago two years
ago
in Zagreb or where was that I'm not sure
we're not sure okay but Bishop C6 was a
new move
um before that Magnus played B3 in that
last game
so exactly in this position after rookie
b2b3 that looks highly
normal I would say is your fee and
Shadow Bishop takes C6 uh giving up
your best minor piece just to double the
pawns what do you think about them
apples Nasi something that you're
attracted to I'm not familiar with the
English opening but why it looks good to
me
okay it's like a long-term Advantage
right as long as I don't get checkmated
right true that Queen D5 Bishop H5 but
uh just for double pawns you're giving
up the two Bishops and uh wow I I find
that a remarkable decision I love by the
way bringing the queen back into the
center posting up with Queen D5 Bishop
H3 included on the board now Queen's on
D5 right not 100 sure the bishop is
perfect here Queen D5 would have likely
provoked an F2 F3 anyway
um now the follow-up for black that's
the question should he do the Rover
rookie six
where are you going
just putting it over there right getting
it close
I'm a little bit more attracted to F5 F4
I would love for you to undouble my
pawns any captures on B6 which opened up
my Rook I would uh oh I would accept
that with open arms
um
Mira do you have any ideas here for
black
uh while rookie 6 is one of the
suggestions interestingly computer
prefers white well just a tiny bit but
but still insists on white being
slightly better uh perhaps Queen D5
wasn't uh wasn't the best and computer
goes for rookie 6 immediately even
though it's not it's not evident what
the threat is perhaps you just go to G6
and push the H board later so there is
nothing immediately but kind of some
long term initiative and also Rook on E6
does a good job of protecting the C6
sport Tabby has captured a pawn he's
traded on E3 Bishop takes E3 Knight
takes E3 and oh wow
x82 inviting Rook take C6 Queen takes B2
pardon me Queen takes B2 you can take
and take but then black will have a past
a pawn we saw Queen C2 and we caught up
with the players Rook
indeed I would that was why I kind of
questioned whether I needed to
um
to put my Bishop on H3 for the moment
okay well Rook takes B2 is rather
serious question is can I oh that was
not the question I expected I the
question I was going to ask is can I
take on A6 C6 in that case you'd have to
take with the queen and not the Rook
because the a uh the rook and Aid is
saying Knight C4 defends the pawn hits
E5 prepares the move Rook A1 and that's
a bit of a relief Bishop E6 now Queen
takes Rook takes now Fabi doesn't have
to worry about losing his Bishop on H3
that's a good thing Rook takes B2 Knight
takes C6 the the point however is think
of the majority that white has he's got
these um very nice Five Pawns
on the center King side versus these two
passers that will be on split on C7 and
A7 feels like a nice something that
Magnus can certainly work with as Magnus
repairs ideas of King F2 Rook A6
it I would really want to push my
central pawns DNE far but because
Black's Rook is on the second rank that
doesn't look that attractive exactly I'm
also thinking uh to keep those pawns on
E2 and D3 first I would love to to I I
want to maintain the Knight and Bishop
tension I'd love to be able to post my
Rook
on the a file and play King F2 so first
of all not allowing the trade right of
night versus Bishop if I lose the Knight
for the bishop the four Rook ending I
think is a draw I I if I'm in magnus's
mindset I'm playing for a win if I could
just suck the pawn on C7 he did
why that's a different question
Magnus said I'll take it let's see what
you've got now do you go for Rook C8 and
Rook C2 or do you go Rook A7 and put
your
okay maybe you can do both Rook create a
Fandango Rook C2 okay that's that's fair
so Rook c895 A4 King F2
and our meet Rook C2 with Knight E3
okay so I'm expecting King F2 Rook C8
and A4 on the board right
it's time for King F2 because you kind
of want to make sure this guy is overly
protected
and they feel it feels
no real long things I'll put it like
that but King
f
2 a mirror jump in here uh it's an extra
Pawn for white but you can certainly say
that black has its counter chances uh
while computer fences white anyway uh
Knight E3 or King F2 both being both
being good moves
slightly less than the ball in White's
favor so well you could say that black
has some gone to play exactly once again
we don't know how much of a contemplate
that is King F2 okay that move funnily
enough for me that move was actually
required right it fits the needs of the
position but it was the the longest
thing of the game
and we have our first result Judah has
won his game against lapulesco
my pick of the tournament to uh start
the day uh Knight E3 so he's got both
King F2 and Knight E3 on the board now
the the bishop is actually dominating
the knight in some measure in the sense
that it no more Knight C4 and two good
squares are being covered now this Rook
kind of perturbs me but if I play a move
like Rook here
raid
yeah I just want to make sure that I
keep the the the the the a pawn under a
lock and key right the criminal you
don't want it to escape and there we go
so the Knight C4 okay that's a bit of
his
surprise A3
oh geez okay one no I I was about to say
A3 the night was on E3 a moment ago and
A4 would have been met by captures in
Knight C2 so I had this temporary
thought that A3 was a blunder
King
I went into the Rook ending
I think it's a draw
with that past eight Pawn but white king
is so close to taking it yeah but at
some moment
black will take you know
one of the ponds yeah exactly so A2 now
the question is will he give up with
Bishop no he he doesn't either he wants
he wants to ensnare The Rook yeah but
I'll always be able to play Knight D2 I
don't think this was a good move I think
King to D4 and King to C3 is going to
question whether or not you want your
Bishop here but when you play 92 I can
play
by the way we have another breaking
result another victory for Russia
he has the fitted
uh I understand what you're saying so
when the bishop
if the bishop was here
The Rook would defend the bishop
right but now it's hard to get the
bishop on B1
see the repetition if King F2 or K8 King
E3
we are seeing it now but Magnus of
course
trying to apply for more
[Music]
um
right not when I'm looking at this very
very passive oh he does have pardon me
he does have a different idea he puts
his Knight on C3 so that the bishop on
B1
right right too to be three
and then maybe King D2 King C1 King B2
is the idea yes
so yes exactly
whoa whoa whoa F5 invites Knight C3 the
bishop will have as you say to go to B3
also King D2
um
is interesting oh and the big news
Vision has the fitted nepo
Nepal is sharing second coming into this
day right
well again we congratulate uh Magnus on
his winning the exhibition and
now everyone else is playing for the
second place okay so they did get the
this Rook ending that we've been
discussing King B3 of course now
question is what about the opponent then
if King E5 I guess we're not gonna see
that but maybe Pawn ending was
interesting too
I'm down two ponds but my king is very
cool very very fast
that would have been interesting yeah
that was why I thought maybe King B2 and
Rook yeah
but with this time control 10 seconds
for Fabi he doesn't have time to
calculate the pawn ending until the end
no he doesn't and by the way King E6
Magnus is not rushing to take the A2
Pawn
but you're gonna have to play F4
we're gonna play Rook chat and King to
D5 Rook check and King the diva this
looks like a very
simple draw to my eyes Miro uh how do
you feel uh about it for Fabi uh well I
I do have a bit more information read
uh let's jump to that one game that's
remaining it's a game of Richie in
gukash we have
uh our apologies to the players but it
has been the Magnus Carlsen show
that we've been watching looks like a
fortress
every file is closed yes in the night on
E6 is beautiful blockader in fact
but they both have five seconds they're
playing on the increment I kind of like
gokash's position if you can bring your
king I was about to say to the D5 Square
I was going to ask so is black the one
playing for more I think so
with the ideas too although with no time
on the clock it's it's easy for us to
say that he's playing I mean he's under
pressure but which side should he be
playing on oh there we go we have an
answer he's playing B5
yeah I was about to say didn't he just
shed the A5 Pawn as well
so we can capture and play Knight G5 now
now it's it's clearly Richie who's
playing for the win
wait a minute why did I give up the pawn
oh there is Knight A5 check apologies
apologies uh
sometimes that happens uh when you're
trying to push and win sometimes you
over push and that's
what we have here but what about this
Knight end game is it really lost I'm
sure it's winning for white but White's
King is on the king side and b3pon is
quite weak
I was expecting the king to March over
to the queen side uh first of all just
let's get rid of the blockader
night
this is such a delicate end game it
needs for size calculation and you do it
all in seconds
yeah players are playing intuitively now
I feel it's closer to a draw but good
cash has managed to pick up that pawn on
B3 and his King is so 96. oh that's a
visual right you gotta you gotta back
off
your knight will go back to E5 so that
will trap well okay they might repeat
the moves now
which is still trying
but all black ponds are pretty safe so
it's it's hard to imagine
maybe make any progress now
C4
oh no
I'm more worried about the Depot now
than the e-pawn absolutely I would say
that that's the by far the more
dangerous looks winning now for black
king just goes to the king side and
picks up all the pawns or that's a
harvest King F3 and but why not can get
two
or D3 well the answer is because players
are playing on with three seconds on the
clock exactly
it's still looking good for good cash
extra Japan
check but G5 energy fortnite because
there is that move you've got to make
sure that your knight will be able to uh
how do you say sacrifice itself King F7
uh
oh and G8 he couldn't put it on C6
because 95 was first what is Richie
doing Richie's trying to lose this game
for a moment there I thought he had an
easy draw just by you know perpetually
attacking the night yeah now black is
winning exactly he over pressed his hand
on that one and uh
the audience
well when you make four decisive uh
games out of five almost I think I think
they've been playing at about a 60
decisive rate there have been some great
games uh
well let's
let's jump to Croatia with a special
guest
thanks yaser we are here with the
executive director of the grand chess
tour Mr Michael kolarkowski Michael
first of all welcome back to the show
we've been having a lot of fun in this
tournament and I have to say it's been
the Magnus show so far it is indeed
indeed Chris actually this is the last
tournament in our European tour and it's
very exciting because uh Magnus
yesterday actually demonstrated
phenomenal performance
hard to repeat even by to Marshalls
right but he does exceptionally well as
you could see he didn't do that well in
Rapid the same as in Warsaw in previous
tournament but this time he did a little
bit better because the gap between him
and the leader in Warsaw was much bigger
here it was just a walk in the park for
him would you call it a historical nine
out of nine if you count the two rapid
games it's 11 out of 11. yeah
uh yeah I believe you know it is
historical but I believe that even nine
out of nine it's hard to find maybe you
know when Fisher won U.S Championship
with perfect score that's the only
comparison but again it was classical
cheers this is Blitz and bleeds you know
you can have any single error in you out
what is it about the grand Chester that
incentivizes this type of performances
we've seen that in the sync field cup as
well with Fabiano now we see it yeah but
Fabiana did seven and all right yeah in
a row and it was also phenomenal and
nobody as of today could repeat right
yes so it's very difficult to win uh in
a row so many games I believe kaspara
won's like five in a row but not seven
or uh not nine right so it is a
phenomenal performance and it's
absolutely stunning to see this an
audience was ecstatic and even Carlson
himself demonstrated how excited he was
he almost was dancing he was out of out
of stage he was he was indeed Michael
whenever you come on the show you always
give us good news do you have any good
news for us well you or you know that I
always working hard to bring some uh new
tournaments
foreign right now very close to get one
more European stop in Western Europe so
it's already in works but it would be
teaser so everybody can wait a little
bit but I believe in couple of months we
will have already full uh full schedule
for grantchester 2024. that's a great
teaser and we're looking forward to hear
more about that we do have a couple more
stops let's actually take a look at
those couple of stuffs coming up as you
were mentioning the European tour is
over we're going straight to Saint Louis
in November very excited about this one
yes yes it would be very exciting and
I'm sure we will see many interesting
games big fights and
I don't know whether it would be new uh
winner of the grandchild store or it
would be a repetition of 2022. we'll see
how alireza will do Michael thank you
very much for joining us thanks for the
news and we'll see you around sure thank
you guys thank you Christian and thank
you Michael let me get in the commercial
word before I forget it we're going to
check in with our friends at Q Boutique
for a moment and just tell you what
their uh special of the day is it's
going to be a St Louis chess club
stainless steel tumbler show your love
for the St Louis chess club with the
stainless steel travel tumbler features
the chess club's logo printed on the
front a vacuum sealed inner wall keeps
your drinks warm or cold for hours and
the included live lid with its open or
closed position helps prevent spillage
of your favorite drink very important
it's a perfect gift for All Seasons all
seasons and beverage enthusiasts alike
who wrote this copy available in stores
at the Q Boutique St louis.com well
thank you and then and our standings not
see after round 10. Magnus gets ding per
draw right out the gate yes but he still
Remains the three-point lead so Magnus
in the first place and now there's no
more tie for the second Fabiano is in
the clear second because Jan just lost
his game against the nun so Yen remains
in the third place firoza in the clear
fourth and rest of the fields kind of
falling behind exactly uh Miro did
Magnus have any opportunity in this
first game uh while he had and as much
as I'm happy for Fabi who was my pick
you know when we were picking the
winners right and it's also very
important for Fabi in terms of GCT
points but you know for for whatever
reason you want this three magnus's
trick to continue and he had very good
opportunity to do so uh surprisingly
nothing was for white in the end game
but this position uh move 18 right Fabi
just played Rook e to B8 which happens
to be a mistake and not an obvious one
because the move for white was G3 G4
trapping the bishop and well that's
logical but how about Rook takes B2 and
it turns out it turns out that Queen C6
with the tempo is a very important move
and hence Fabi had to play with the
other Rook but that once again how would
you know so Queen takes C6 The Rook is
attacked regards to d8 or f8 it's not so
important and then despite all pieces
being on the board King marches to win
the Bishops King F2 and you cannot stop
King G3 and white is just winning
and later on there was nothing much
really so Fabi from this little moment
he played close to perfect and draw was
a fair result there's been another
couple of very interesting games like
firuja continuing his
all Pursuit I don't know if he's going
to catch Magnus seems unlikely but at
least he's gotten closer to the second
place so his game against Ivan sarich it
was a sicilian and let me see some
around this point so you can guess I
mean there were opposite castles there
were attacks on the king but not so much
from Whiteside the Rogers somehow
managed to block the king side so there
was not much of an attack and sariches
King well there is a lot of threats of
Knight xb3 specifically
and he couldn't find anything better but
to take on D6 and it turns out it
doesn't really help so he took with the
Queen Bishop takes B3 anyway
and yeah it's not much you can do so the
Rojo wins with a direct attack
comes closer to the pedestal and there
was one more game which caught my eye uh
yeah against viciana and that's a you
know which is back if we if we recall
yesterday last couple of rounds it felt
like which is tired which is losing it
in terms of results and also you know
the way he was playing and now he's back
he managed to get get back in form and
what's interesting about this one
he was
open open variation of the rui Lopez by
black captures on e4
and yeah will not go too much into
detail but
up to this point with Bishop C2 and D4
and this and this all that was played
believe it or not among the others in
nepo's game
so I don't know if it was a specific
preparation I don't know if you really
prepare against your opponent in Blitz
but yeah Vichy apparently had everything
prepared
and here yeah after Queen C2 we have two
games Bishop D5 we still have two games
and nepo Nepal was the the only highest
high rated player who played it B take
C3 was the strong move after which white
still fights with an advantage and this
simplistic one takes takes Queen C3 what
happened in the game turns out that
black has a very very promising midnight
D4 so Knight takes Bishop takes white
quarter called wins the pawn just to
realize that after the castle you can't
really develop your pieces you have to
give the pawn back up to which black is
better and wish it went on to win this
one
thank you marrow very very nice indeed
interesting round with four decisive
games one draw but let's take a look at
the pairings of the round coming up
round 11.
going to be an exciting round and we
have Duda playing Magnus Carlson my pick
go yawn
ing
that promises to be a very exciting game
that'll be a backup because it has been
a Magnus Carlson show and then against
rapper and gukesh karwana also a great
game good cash versus Bobby as Luke has
just won to start the event for Bobby I
want to say that draw could be very
crucial it has given him a clear second
and maybe a lot of confidence as well as
being the first player to stop Magnus
precisely
an invitation to the perk defense and
Judas accepted the challenge and played
E4 d76
yeah
and in Poland we saw these two playing
the last round of the blitz where Dura
was just one point behind Magnus and he
could have caught him and then gone into
players right it was very close exciting
game uh when I have been black we used
to call this variation the rat in the
Pacific Northwest and I would play it
with A7 A6 B7 B5 and I would keep my
Bishop still on f8 I would I would say
that the move Bishop f8 to G7 I could
play when I needed it and I was more
interested in playing Knight to D7 and
C5 and saving the tempo uh the move F2
F3 you kind of ask yourself is the
bishop great on and on B7 and I don't
think the answer is yes uh from one
question for you please were you playing
this in the classical with black oh yes
yeah oh yes oh yes because we don't see
it as much in classical no I mean the
perk defense like so many of the
openings and defenses you know it goes
through these fashion changes and today
the Berlin and the Petrov and the Joko
piano they dominate uh but now I'm
seeing a little Sicilian creeping in
more which is uh really good it's a
relief right happy to see it exactly
King B1 okay so now uh Magnus is kind of
committed himself when you play Knight
to G8 to F6 when Bishops coming to H6
you're kind of committing yourself to
getting out of Dodge castles uh long and
that's with C5 because you don't really
want to go short White's attack with
h4h5 in the words of Bobby Fischer sack
sack mate
so they you think Magnus should play H5
here himself or else white okay yes I do
H5 and or H6 actually I do think that
you don't want to see white just happily
you know going up the board but once
black if black plays H5 but he didn't I
was gonna say then there's usually
G-Force Pawn sacrifice to open things up
and as well as the square G5 to plant on
uh Knight is my CG for now anyways one
of the one of the most celebrated games
ever uh Gary Kasparov versus uh
[Music]
topolov from Bulgaria the pearl of icons
a he played Bishop E3 to H6 and and not
playing H4 did Gary Kasparov because of
the move H6 Queen F2 G4 okay an
indication that uh White has been slowed
down by H6 I think Magnus just Bluff
short Castle I think he's going
I think so too I think the move E7 E6 is
designed to allow the queen to come to
E7 it's not been easy for black to play
the move C7 C5 especially with the queen
on F2 lined up to prevent that move so
Queen E7 and castles long but now that
you've got H6 and G6 once you play G5 I
play H5 you play H5 I play G5 you kind
of bypass H5 looks attractive because
after G5 I can follow up with F4 agreed
agreed I like that too and if you're a
castle long I guess you could
deal with that with F6 or is that
creating too many holes in the position
I'll have to see it by the way the move
Bishop G2 does invite Knight C4 and
that's a kind of a move that you feel
really good about getting in because
it's going to provoke the bishop to come
back to C1 and it does mean that well
it's going to have a sicilian flavor
once I get in the movie C7 C5 Bishop uh
unless Magnus chooses to just play Queen
E7 and long Castle
still an option
uh Miro uh
a lot of chewing and throwing all 16
pawns on the board it's still not easy
to make it a judgment as to who's
playing for an advantage
uh well right you are yes movie 11 was a
novelty in fact so before that even
though the position is not very common
you can still find well a dozen of games
in the database uh Queen F2 was a new
move E6 Knight fd7 all kind of confirmed
by the engine but you guessed right
white is better and then Bishop G2 is an
unlucky move after which it looks like
Magnus is taking over so C5 is correct
and the most principal Knight E2 takes
takes and queen to B6 and exactly as
you've mentioned black all of a sudden
has a very appealing Sicilian on the
board right I mean by Sicilian standards
white was doing something really strange
yeah with night on H3
Bishop on G2 and again this Knight on C4
very handsome devil there you know
nicely positioned against the white king
Rook H1 to E1 I was about to say that uh
it's unfortunate for us the night the
night on H3 defends the queen e6e5 is
not a threat uh because the Knight can
move this moment might be the Moment of
Truth short Castle or long castle Yeah
at a certain moment you just have to
declare uh what what you're going to do
with the king I probably go short at
this point because I don't believe that
White's attack after H5 G5 Knight takes
G5 is going to work however you can cast
a long and still attack on the queen
side you can attack in your King on B8
or A8 and still continue with a sicilian
type of attack on the queen side B5 B4
by Magnus a kind of indication that he
might be looking to play the move Knight
A3 check
if Queen on F2 was not defended I agreed
agreed agreed uh but that move I I saw
duda's reaction to the move
I know he made a Grimace makes you
nervous yeah yeah like
[Music]
okay that uh what that that wasn't you
know when you put your Bishop on G2 you
better be playing F4 F5 or F4 E5 to make
this bishop come alive if not it's time
to get rid of that night I I would start
to get nervous uh Bishop F1 takes C4 uh
or F4 I mean you and clock times at Nasi
uh Magnus down to one minute and 22
seconds and Magnus has two and a half
and a half or so
yeah dealing with this position with one
minute on the clock not not easy not
easy Knight B3 explains why Dura is
offering a queen trade to make it easier
for him to play but by the way uh if I'm
in magnus's shoes this is a real relief
because it means that I can
leave my king in the center and in fact
the the king in the center defending D6
is going to be a very happy camper
impossible to kick the king away and
also again I I you've heard me mention
and that's a handsome night um black
pieces are definitely more active it's
just that white doesn't really have any
weaknesses so it should still be equal
I always think in terms of who's it
easier to play and these last moves
indicate to me that A5 A4 was a serious
concern also including the move Rook on
h8 to C8 with that attack so for me it's
easier to play with black
I would definitely agree with that but
white should be able to oh
yeah again if you were asked me what the
weaknesses are well F3 is a potential
weakness the Knight Will One Day land on
E5 but you're right I mean it's not like
white has anything terribly going for
him
by the way big trade now
well I think
I definitely like black so we have
Bishop versus knight right openc file
Rook has an outpost on C3 that's a big
going directly after the weakness on F3
it's a fortunate fortunately I can meet
Rook C3 with Knight to d3s just to block
the thread of Rook takes F3 but it's not
it's like kind of temporary the Knight
is on D3 by the way getting a report
that Richie and fishy have drawn there
they've drawn their game okay
Rook C3 good move I like this I I mean
you you gotta
in chess you have to kick back you can't
just you know hold and hold and hold and
hold but you have to remind your
opponent that you're in the game as well
and I like this move Rook on E1 to A1 as
it does
uh prepare the move A3 in counter play
you want to
you want to have fun too you want to put
your Rook on A7
so I like this move I think that's that
was probably the best I
guess I play three otherwise for the
whole game yeah
and a little Grimace and growl there
from Magnus as Magnus says yeah that's a
good move I should I should have taken
that into account
marrow uh how how does the engines
evaluate the current moment well
currently it's roughly equal it was
preferable for black just a few moves
ago right yeah okay one seems to be a
good move truly Bishop Ace well better
follow up with A3 now immediately before
it's too late exactly and we do have a
trade
well giving up the the bishop for the
night that uh
that imbalance
and again black has a slightly better
position we have more active Rooks but
it's just not enough in The Rook ending
too well for me the question is can I
including the move G5 could I worm my
king to the F4 Square goat like G5 King
F6 yeah okay because if you start with
kin F6 I think I'll face that with F4
that was what I was thinking maybe J5
maybe I I go G5 and again if I ever get
my king you know
uh by the way just as I was suggesting
that King to F6 to E5 might be on
Black's agenda to play D4 now just don't
have Five Pawns in a row I
all right ah the old five pound attack I
remember well let's put the D4 and then
if I actually looks good he went with E5
now this move H5 would be a great move
if you had a knight that you could plant
on the F5 Square for the moment I don't
see
oh
dude can we expecting G5 I sure was I
sure I sure thought that Duda was going
to keep the king side closed but with
the captures it gets down to five
seconds
Magnus 20 seconds
you know this is equal but there's still
tricks in the position there sure is and
this trading the H5 Pawn for the F4 Pawn
I have to feel that's the black said
Magnus also has A4 option you don't have
to take F4 you could take the B3 he's
reaching for the a pawn he was about to
play A4 thought a little bit better of
it no I think he went for a form
dude have reached and quickly played F5
so equal material right pawns are equal
yes
still feels like a draw is the most
likely outcome
oh wow big upset as gookish
defeated fabriano when he's on a road
two out of two for good cash today nice
start for the day no question about that
A3 Rook A6
821 A2
okay now it's two versus two this should
be just it should be a draw
in the offing
six give me four
a one against one
yeah this should be this will be agreed
to a draw very soon
well with these draws is to start the
the game uh
the fight for second becomes much more
intense but that's as nepo just won his
game against firoshima big win for Nepal
yes especially after uh the loss and do
we have no that's all of our results uh
two decisive games three draws uh fill
in the gaps for us Miro after we focused
on uh the game of Duda and Magnus uh
while Fabi Fabi could have easily won
his game and while it was just you know
a tactical oversight in completely
winning position which led to his defeat
so he was uh well quite a tense opening
before we managed to outplay good cash
that's position of the move 27 we are
talking about where gookash went for D4
D5 rather speculative Pawn sacrifice uh
he according to an engine once again he
should have just kept the position kept
the tension but easier said than done
when you're playing Blitz right so the
whole point is that you sacrifice the
pawn you have to spend the tempo on
rookie 3 but you are looking to play E5
E6 open some files the Knight possibly
gets to D5 to F5 which is important
later
uh right but it turns out it doesn't
work tactically and up to the point okay
I'll be moving fast forward up to the
point Fabi was playing perfectly E6 yes
okay F6 just block everything here and
here and B3 and you've set a just say B
so B2 would have won a game for Fabi and
Rook C8 somewhat careless yes he wants
to swap the queen so the king is safe
but check and queen H5 and all of a
sudden you cannot really stop a
Checkmate so it was just a one move
blunder
instead of winning and catching up a
little bit with Carlson well securing
your second spot and now after far be
lost it's NEPA who's in a clear second
position they leap from one another in
fact let's go to Croatia and get an
Insider's perspective Christian
you know well let's analyze uh the last
couple of games that you guys didn't
catch and I'm going to start with the
game between lupuscu and Ivan sarichen I
have to say lupuscu was so close to
finally getting his first Victory but he
didn't let's take a look at what
happened he played this move H3 in the
king's Indian once again Yvonne is
showing very a very aggressive stance
obviously he wants to win as well he
wants to maybe perhaps try to catch up
with all the other players lupolescu is
also looking for his first victory of
the tournament take on C6 take only five
a very nice move by lupuscu
transitioning into an end game with a
pawn up there is some compensation for a
black obviously due to the activity of
the pieces take a look at this the night
coming with Tempo on B4 then the bishop
comes with Tempo but lupinesco is doing
a great job of locking everything up
rook to D3 it looks good it's not good
because it allows this very nice
transition you are giving back the pawn
in fact you giving up an exchange as
well but right now you're just winning
because of this Knight on C5 beautiful
night on C5 and after the transition The
Rook invades the bishop is absolutely
this is plus five and yeah unfortunately
for him he didn't win take a look at
this it was a transition into a two
pawns and game extra two points end game
uh for white for lupulasco in this one
and I'm going to fast forward to the
last final moment he got everything done
he pushed his pawns and right now he
only needs to find this move E5 that
finishes the game that's really cool
because Bishop B5 Knight F7 exactly
and then you just take the the piece
right and leave the king takes you close
this diagonal wow that's a very nice
movie and if you don't if you refuse the
sacrifice then I just push my king and
this is
big missed opportunity for lupuscu what
were you having your eyes on yeah I was
checking the game between the layers of
the future must tell you that young
played a very very nice game uh it
started with some English opening but it
was very tricky actually I like this
move of Jan somewhere here
um when he played Knight C4 you know the
idea is to take on B2 and then to play
Knight A4 yes what a nice trick yes at
the opening so and after B3 96 look at
this 94 looks like a logical move yes
you just put your knight at the center
but believe it or not after C6 black is
actually much better yes so what
happened in the game actually just led
to the position which was really worse
for white instead of this I could have
played something like E4 and then maybe
push it five or take on D5 but what
happened in the game he took on C6 and
look what E5 and boss you know this is
our hanging there were still some tricks
but actually yeah it seemed like
calculated all of it and I mean after a
few moves you can just understand what
happened this bishop on F1 visas are not
developed and black species are really
good he has two Bishops and you know
after a few moves it became clear that
position is really dead I love to see
some Groove and representation in this
tournament we haven't seen much and this
is a successful display of what the
groomfield can do yeah so the position
was already minus five for in favor of
yan and he managed to win it without any
problems he's a pawn down in this
position but it is absolutely reading
yes you can see yes what's going on
let's take a look at the standings as we
enter uh round three of today's rounds
of course still leading is Magnus
Carlson still a three points Advantage
uh Fabiano uh slow down that was a very
difficult defeat against gukesh as Miro
show then nepo is keeping Pace right now
in second position important second
position because we know right now to be
honest these players are fighting for a
second position Magnus is too far right
you see how critical this game was for
the standings in Nepal one and alirez is
on the fourth position right now because
of that game as well
managed to catch up a little bit with
the leaders yes so he's on the fixed
position that better day for him today
great absolutely I'm happy absolutely
yesterday was so difficult yes right
today a better day for Vichy but we are
coming shortly with a round four of
today's rounds we're going to go on a
short commercial break and we'll
reassuring
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen singfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chest lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchest hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
foreign
[Music]
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
act over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85 000
students in both in school and after
school programs we created the select
chess training program in the junior
select chess training program in order
to elevate the skill level in students
across the St Louis area these students
receive professional training from Grand
Master varusha nicobian other programs
include chess cops a partnership with
the St Louis Police Department looking
to improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 250 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Genie care sinkfield anyone
can learn how to understand chest
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back after
two rounds of Blitz or 11 if you prefer
these are our standings Nazi Magnus
Carlson are still in the lid but things
have changed and for the second place
now Yani punishes in clear second and
Fabiano is in third yeah Paul vote of
Paul alting over one another alireza 16
and a half points he's in the mix as
well tell us about the pairings for this
upcoming round 12. all right we have
Carlson playing gookish by the way cool
cash just won two games in a row so
we'll see yeah that's got to be our
Marquee matchup Carolina against Anan a
brilliant backup Robert against feroza
backup too I might say a neighbor
playing localesco how many times have my
head is there and search against it oh
boy exciting around 12 action coming up
Magnus Carlson getting Bing for two
draws which goes to show how
extraordinary was his result yesterday
going 9-0 because the two draws have
actually been very well played games I
mean and Marrow jump in with uh your
thoughts on those two draws as well uh
well so I guess he can kick himself a
bit against Fabi right but then the next
one was well fairly fought and he just
couldn't do anything about about
sarichi's defense right now my eyes are
still on those two Fabi and nipple who's
gonna take the second apparently for
Fabi it matters more because he is well
positioned in GCT standings right he has
played one event less so that means he
had very good chance for Fabi in GCT
perceived exactly well the winner of the
Bucharest uh the clear first winner so
he definitely looking very good there
but that fight for a second Napo and
again
yeah I was about to say just a second
ferrous is definitely in that mix as
well uh everything to play for as we
have
seven eight seven games left seven games
left yeah so uh great stuff
and here at mentioning those uh GCT
standings at Nasi Wesley weslas in the
lead and young not far behind but like
Mira mentioned Bobby has only played one
event so exactly after today this is
going to change he's going to likely
getting somewhere in the 10 point
vicinity of 10 points let's just say and
Duda will also gain points so we'll see
it's likely those two will overtake
over time right yes yes exactly both
Duda and Papi in that graphic there
okay okay this is a little bit calm as
we're getting ready for this round as
well who is that at the board is sitting
on their boards okay
that's got to be very painful because
it's so close to winning completely
winning position and just one blunder
well it wasn't just the blender it was
the strange part about the blunder he's
just he's got two connected past bonds
he's pushing his beep on up the board if
he continues to go with the flow and as
Miro was showing us if he continued to
play B2 he wins right he's steady plays
this movebook C8 and in a single move I
mean H5 comes out of nowhere Knight F5
or Green Archer five as Magnus uh looks
to get
get back to his winning ways I want to
say Miro and he's playing the 17 year
old gookash uh probably in terms of the
head-to-head I don't expect that they
played that often
if I don't just the Rapids right yeah I
hope you get to see it but I mean
cash has been on this level for a year
or two so yes yeah couldn't have been
that many games yet Hardy hand class as
they are off the 45.
and the Queen's Gambit accepted uh proud
to say that uh uh it's really making a
big comeback I want to say uh today in
the world of top level chess Queen a for
check is Magnus looking to transpose
into Catalan later some kinds of Catalan
right so that I know this was an option
for sure 97 Queen takes uh C4 and A7 A6
for sure
we go 97 now you don't have to take on
C4 right away like you say a Catalan
with G3 certainly uh fully playable here
one line I remember is G3 in this exact
position there's the move C6 you go
Queen takes C4 and then there's the move
E5
and thanks to Queen A5 check you can
pick up the pawn so G3 may allow the C6
business so is the line after he takes
E5 Knight takes E5 or queen A5 check
first 95 95 otherwise Bishop D2 exactly
95. and that is why Queen takes C4 first
if you want to play a Catalan with G3 uh
you you want to see black playing E6
this looks like a
like he's playing for more like a knight
beat Knight C3 and E4 C7 C5 I like this
move especially with the bishop on G5 it
means that Queen A5 check if you play
Bishop D2 it's sort of like
he moved your Bishop twice I'm so proud
so this is still Theory right
I think so there's some games in the
database but
been in a while it's been a while eat uh
E3 we have E3 now again uh because
you've played the move Bishop G5
I do start to think
I hate being in pins I think every chess
player understands me very very well
when I say you know being in pins is not
a lot of fun so I start to think about
getting out of the pen and if I can do
it with a gain of tempo I find myself
very encouraged uh Queen B6 and Gucci
just captured on D4 asking the question
do you want to recapture with a pawn
isolated Queen Pawn you recapture with
the Knight or if you go Queen takes yeah
I was going to say queen cake Bishop C5
that's a that's a Tempo green D3 Maybe
yeah but it's the tempo you you you help
me develop the tempo I one of my
favorite things in chess is developing
with the tempo don't you agree with me
Miro that uh besides actually capturing
your opponent's pieces which is the best
of all you know taking your opponent's
pieces off the board developing pieces
with the tempo always brought me great
happiness right you are I think there is
a specific one when you can see some
position that you can get in the game
and then you have the opportunity to get
the same one but with the tempo up and
this is just stops your brain from
working you're going for it right you're
just so happy I can have the same
position sometimes a bad position but
with the tempo it feels good Queen A4 we
is still in theory by the way
uh not anymore that should be five rare
E3 super rare okay and yeah of the C
takes d42 games Queen takes was never
played never played
Queenie for surprised me because
Asos you're still living your queen in
under tempos right Knight B6 and so on
right the castles Knight B6 is a
possibility where did you like him to go
H4 D3 Queen to D3
sure we'll go to E2 Knight C3
and Castle Rook D1
okay I kind of feel
oops
I'm always very happy when you Retreat
you know you can Retreat to D3 you can
Retreat to D2 but out of 10 moves Magnus
moved his Queen five times already and
that's not good typically not no no I
don't fall in love with a piece to the
detriment of everything else uh Queen A4
Queen C2 feels like Magnus is
floundering just a little bit a little
bit hasn't found his rhythm you can only
get away with this kind of play with the
white pieces yes now with black not with
black
because of Bishop D3 castles and Knight
A4 one day the Knight is going to come
to A4 forking the the queen and Bishop
gukesh played the move Bishop B4 just
anticipating five now okay he took right
away because he's looking for 94 as an
option takes tape sorry and not see that
was going to be my question that black
can separate White's Queen side pawns
which is split yeah split the puns yeah
which is good for
for black yes definitely and uh you know
it's funny even when the players are
playing a position that's very unusual
they try to seek patterns that they're
familiar with uh the queen dropped back
to C7 because we know when we're playing
against the isolated Pawn B7 B6 Bishop
B7 Queen C7 is very very good we're
trying not to commit our Pawn to early
whether it be with H6 or G6 trying to
keep the them intact on the king side
our Pawn Shield I mean to say B7 B6 if
black manages to just put his Bishop on
the E4 Square all issues are solvent I'm
sure was interesting I mean provoking E5
but I think E5 is what something black
wants to do anyways not always with it
when the pawn is on E6 it means that
we've got this kind of anchor square and
maybe there's
you know the possibility that the pawn
is more of a Target on E5 after the move
Bishop F4 by the way it yeah I guess he
had to play E5 Queen C6 was the
alternative in any case rookie Rook to
D1
um quickly marrow did who succeeded in
the opening did Black equalized did
white maintain an edge uh well no Edge
for white whatsoever starting from you
know like move six move seven right
comfy is not happy with White's position
he still has the equality though despite
well you know if you'd ask me not
looking at the computer I would start to
prefer black perhaps somewhere on this
point but computer has it as as equal
well the question for me is how are we
going to be meeting Queen
F5 because Queen F5 basically
starts to post up any trades of the C3
Pawn for the E5 Pawn as white I'm
encouraged by whoa Bishop D3 that was
not
uh
queen of five immediately was a mistake
because of Bishop E4
Bishop E4
and yes good point Sorry Bishop E4 on
this move by the way uh if you capture
on C3 I capture on H7 and D7 is hanging
uh on a good day the idea of posting
with the bishop on F5 that becomes
attractive clock times a factor
they they
they're about 30 seconds more by the way
Madness is encouraging Bishop takes F3
he's thinking that after G takes F3 you
can't get over there over there meaning
you know on the king size two nights
looks like a long-term Advantage oh but
go cash is going for it right
I mean you're you're always kind of
thinking if I if I do damage my
opponent's king-size structure uh what's
the result going to be now get out of
that pin exactly
oh there we go we haven't answered you
moved the pin as simple as that
sometimes you know simple as answers are
the correct answers exactly in this case
he's got a an outpost for his Knight on
C5 but I'm thinking the two Bishops here
despite White's damage Pawn structure
the two Bishops
uh this mirror looks very good for
Magnus uh while still relatively equal
according to the machine F4 note to be
the most precise but last move Queen B7
actually shifts it in White's favor
enough to Bishop H3 the move that Magnus
played instantaneously white is better
and perhaps much better well that that
Bishop whoa whoa whoa whoa the bishop on
G2 incredibly powerful and now we have
to walk into the spin Knight E4 suddenly
I really don't like it anymore Rook to D
I think he has to play F5 and which he
did I mean that's a move you you play
reluctantly I must say you're not eager
to play a move like F5 Rook D1 I would
have won a pawn F3 would have won a pawn
pawn alert well he might be winning more
than a pawn no
and now go cash is down to 15 seconds
against magnus's minute and a half
oh then it's yeah it's Dreadful now
uh the bishop is going to post itself
both nights at the moment with like
Queen B3
I like Queen B3 I also love posting up
this bishop because I like this idea of
F3 after I play F3
correct that's that's what it's all
about
never forget about that always count the
little guys F2 F3
F3 is just you don't want to make that
move upon in front of your amazing
Bishop true that's why Magnus is
hesitating yeah but it did win a pawn
even though you're right it is an
amazing Bishop
C6
well again it just it has that feel that
Magnus is taking over the game but he
still hasn't won anything I mean Lucas
is keeping everything
defended for the time being and material
is even but position wise it's terrible
it feels like a dominating position for
white again I'm kind of drawn to F3 as
is Magnus but now we're not attacking
exactly exactly
but Knight F6 Queen C2 no he didn't by
the way Nepal already won his game
against lupuscu so he is uh securing his
second place
in the standings yeah
uh Bishop F1 we were talking about the
pawn being on F3 blocking the bishop the
bishop looking to play to C4 Magnus down
to 30 seconds now against four seconds
and uh good question this is Bishop D6
just winning the piece
feels good
he's done it
do Tron Queen check King F2
wait we're threatening to capture it on
f8 once we capture on f8
that's
but there's Queen H2 okay maybe maybe in
a good day you have a Perpetual check
but if I doubt oh Rook C7 is very nice
now it's oh and Rook takes G7 checks and
and he wins magnus's back on his own in
strike yes he is well let's jump to the
game of Fabi and Vichy Anand
prevent equal material but
bishop and the Knight against two
knights
we just saw night at four
nice hitting D3
maybe black is
slightly better if he can get his Queen
on G6 oh but wait a minute uh Vichy just
voluntarily stepped back not much time
on his clock nine seconds
so I think he's just trying to make
solid moves and not blunt or anything
at the same time he's looking for his
own counter play because there was
vision is like okay where does it go
where does it go
that's one thing that audience
will not understand
five seconds on the clock yeah how
even the most obvious moves become
difficult to see it's well also your eye
you you're playing a move like Queen D7
but then your eye is drawn to the fact
that Queen B7 does attack at peace so
it's like let's let's retreat with the
tempo then you don't have time to
hesitate and double check and that's
when you panic exactly a lot of chewing
and throwing uh from both players is
they're trying to outmaneuver one
another there's a weak Pawn on E5 well I
think it's Fabi who is trying too yes no
question about it and Vichy is basically
trying to
kick back White's pieces
well why Drew got on the seventh rank
that's something it sure is and King G8
the pawn on F7 along with the pawn on E5
Israel are are tender two seconds Queen
one
second Vichy another one second
Queen B5 on vichy's agenda play it
quickly
he's not playing it quickly Queen B5
machine let's go I think that's that's
the lead he plugged he flagged he he
flagged and Bobby hasn't seen it yet but
what
they're not looking at the clock they're
just playing as if everything yeah and
then vishi says I'm sorry I'm down he
called it on himself uh important game
let's go to uh Richie and alireza uh
somebody's upon up and it's Richie it's
Richie
of course this is a joke
we have five seconds on the clock so
anything is possible
so there you go the same what is the
strategy here for why to win do we want
the king in front of the pawn yes so we
have to keep pushing the king yes
yes and we do want the pond at the board
I think on a dream would be more or less
to have the King on G7 oh Somebody
almost flagged he also almost put the
queen on e4 where he was traded right
G5 with a Tempo so that's very nice now
at some moment
darn it some moment you want to be able
to play King to G6 King H5 King G6 but
now it's a prepared Perpetual yes yeah
a very simple one and
alireza has spotted it
yeah
a very appreciative audience for a very
exciting round at 12 coming to a close
there and uh mural if you don't mind
fill in the gaps what happened uh while
a lot of stuff happened if Russia was
totally lost but this one uh I'll leave
to our colleagues in Zagreb so let me
take a quick look at nepo's game against
Constantine lupulesco because Napa isn't
in a good position in the tournament
he's playing the The Outsider and he
goes for one well interesting strategy
he's not trying at all he just keeps the
position solid and waits for his
opponent to well do the job himself
and yeah so the Catalan in I say after
15 moves you have this which is a
symmetrical structure white typically
well perhaps slightly better you know
this is a little bit more organized but
not more than that and up to the point
and for quite a long time
keeps up right so nothing for white here
and then NEPA finally perhaps plays a
very short on time NEPA goes for G4 so
far nothing still G5 Queen to C7
offers a queen straight King G3 and you
could have traded the Queens you could
have gone king of Fate H takes H takes
all fine G6 is somewhat suspicious E4
and this is the moment where lupulasco
having five seconds on the clock he
makes a crucial mistake which isn't you
know it isn't something on this night
takes night takes already better for
white and then
very impulsive thing to do is to give a
check and this check just gives the game
away because F3 yeah of course white
doesn't resign white blocks and then you
move the Knight away he he went to B4
and the Knight was taken in one move but
you move the Knight away it's a check
for by Rook D7
and this is how white winds on a spot
so that's one and there was quite a
perhaps not so important game in terms
of tournament standings but quite an
interesting game between sarich and Duda
okay there was there was a funky opening
it's a Karo Khan Knight f3d5 Knight C3 D
takes Knight takes Knight F6 Queen E2
well
a favorite of many tricky plays right
you expect black to go Knight D7 Jack
made it uh well not with these guys so
to speak and yeah and a few few more
moves yeah Queen F4 is funny
in few more moves we've gotten to this
end game which you would expect to be
well no problem for black
but
so here here H4 and there are some
problems with the Bishops in order not
to give white the advantage of two
Bishops black girls Knight D7 of the
castles captures here goes Bishop G6 H5
Bishop D3 Rook D3 and despite the fact
that everything is equal right not so
many pieces left it turns out that why
it's much better Rook d8 Rook D1 trade
on D3 and those pawns are weak those
pawns are soft so some rugby trees at
the right moment Bishop E7 Bishop E3 B6
and here white could have gotten close
to decisive Advantage by playing this
move C2 C4 so he wants C5
and if B5 Rook A3 would be and if Black
Goes C5
the king
starts going to a four provokes a7a6 and
then white goes A3 B4 so once again I
mean it's perhaps a plan for a classical
game not for the blades right and later
on
G6
H6 and G5 and G5 happens to be a
brilliant defensive resource because
in few moments seems like quite winning
a pawn and indeed he does but yeah
Bishop at Baron Bishop faith is clever
so now if you take with the pawn black
will be able to take
so you have to trade the Rooks
you're a pull-up but it turns out it's
just a fortress so even was trying for
another 20 moves but couldn't really
break through so we have a couple of
more games to analyze but let it be with
Christian and Anastasia
thanks Miro yes we were actually
watching uh this game between Richie and
alireza and this is a crucial game for
the battle for second position we see
that hitting up with Fabiano winning his
game uh nepo is uh winning his games as
well and Ali Reza needs to at least not
lose in order to stay in contention for
second place and let's take a look
because he was very very close to losing
you guys caught the end of it but he was
in a much worse situation all throughout
the game take a look at this
um Richie with the white pieces played a
quite unambitious opening you know
Knight F3 E3 B3 but this is Blitz you
can play pretty much anything you want
at the beginning it's all going to be
decided later on in the game F6 I would
say that's a bit too aggressive creating
some weaknesses I don't really like this
move F6 but once again as I was
mentioning anything can be played at the
beginning but I have to say Richie
played a really really clean game and
Ali Reza was showing a lot of ambitious
plans on the king side with the move G4
taking a pawn but weakening your king so
much and that might be problematic and
it was problematic in fact he got a
completely winning position as you can
see or black is two pawns up but I'm
going to recover a lot of those pawns
maybe with interest as well
F4 Bishop to C3 take one Pawn do not
touch this Rook you might be wondering
hey give me that free root thank you
very much that's a Checkmate you get the
Rook I get the Checkmate uh fair trade
Rook to C2 Bishop to B4 Bishop to B2 and
you can see how bad and how passive
black species are in the position and
white is just making the Right Moves
pushing getting now finally I'm a pawn
up finally and also the king is not that
safe on G8 right with all these pieces
swarming around it and as you can see by
the way beautiful yes it takes neither
seven nice very beautiful I mean how can
how did Ali Reza save this position is
beyond me
still by the way the computer is saying
at this point plus seven so this is
completely winning for white I'm picking
up another Pawn this was the critical
moment after Rook to C8 the exchange of
the Rooks which perhaps was not the
correct practical decision nevertheless
you're still winning at the same time
it's all about the tenacity of Ali Raza
he's very tenacious and he is never
giving up and he it paid off for him F5
B3 and now he plays the bad move the bat
push F6 a loud black back into the game
The Right Move which would have won the
game is A6 now if you do go b2a7 B1 we
get Queens I have to pause this is going
to be winning yes I'm going to cover
with the queen it's going to take some
time but it's two points right
this should be way if you try to catch
my uh Pawn with the move King to B6 the
problem is now your king is on the B
file so what I can do is go here F6 also
it's a little bit further away I see but
I see what your point F7 B1 f8 but now
it's not that easy to touch that pawn
right because if you take it I go Queen
to A8 and now finally I'm picking up the
queen so it's going to take some time to
actually touch that pawn on A6 in the
meantime I'm just going to be able to
push my king push my pawn and actually
get the victory in this one so big
missed opportunity I have to say for a
rich report you guys caught the end of
that end game I have to say Ali Reza
just tenacious great defense from a
completely losing position what game
were you I was checking for download
game against vision and I must say it
was like Italian perfect opening and
they were you know playing this position
which everybody knows I mean
for ages they were just exchanging
pieces one of the other I will just want
to show the critical one because it
balanced game until the very very last
moment where supposedly we should missed
this bishop H6 right but and after that
he collapsed I mean he played rookie six
and later he just uh collapsed just to
mention it and yes uh Bishop to H6 he
already lost on time his time already
ran out at this point at this point yes
because okay like actually black is
still not so lost after 94.
um I mean he's still in the game and if
you take uh this Pawn I take on H6 and
D4
um postpone they still exists on the
board here so good good result for
father very good result for Fabi
bouncing back after a difficult loss
against uh gookish and we will be going
on a short interview Anastasia you met
up with a tennis player yes so the top
player one of the top players in the
tennis players in the world born as
George and also he has the best Croatian
player so he visited today the plane
venue and he also talked to us a little
bit how was this experience for him
let's take a look
we are here with Borno Church who is the
one of the top players tennis players in
the world and also the best player of
Croatia so today you you had this very
interesting experience to make the first
symbolic movement the game and the chess
on the chessboard and also had
experience to watch the games here
they're playing oh how did you like it
yeah yeah absolutely it was it was very
very cool experience for me I've never
been on the on the on the chess
tournament and I was I was really
looking forward to this and obviously I
I I
also saw the players and I and I met the
players so I'm just very very happy to
be here yeah so and which board did you
make the first move and who is who are
you rooting for in this tournament uh I
need to root obviously obviously for the
charge uh also he's my favorite player
and I've been I've been following him a
little bit in the in the last few months
so yeah hopefully he came in the
tournament yeah
I'm actually very very bad in the chest
to be honest so I just played you know
for fun and and relax a little bit after
after all the matches but uh again uh
unfortunately I'm um I'm just not very
good do you play online or do you play
with your friends who taught you to play
actually
um
actually my friends and I uh I would say
I I explain mostly online online is
mostly and all the Summers with the
friends like this but uh but mostly
online when I have free time on the
tournaments yeah for sure and what are
your plans for the future where do you
go next uh plans for the future I'm
actually going for location for the
couple of days it's been it's been a
very very tough season uh and at this
time in tennis we actually have
um I would send you a couple of days
where where we can take a break so I'm
gonna go home and I'm I'm gonna just
relax for a couple days yeah so have a
great vacations and enjoy the tournament
thank you very much thank you
thank you Anastasia and here are our
standings after 12 rounds of Blitz
Magnus Carlson in the lead with still
three-point lead uh Second Place Yanni
promise 19 points and Half Point behind
Neville is Fabiano caruana and thanks to
saving that game alireza again he
remains in the mix and through the magic
of Television we just want to show you
that this she was playing and playing
because his clock had expired and then
despite the fact that he's now lost the
game on Time the players continue for
quite a number of moves and at this
point I'm a little bit surprised that
the Arbiters are not stepping in because
you would expect that the Arbiters would
be the first to say okay excuse me
but both players are not even aware
until that she says okay that's it I'm
done
and the pairings for round 13.
sarich is playing Magnus Carlson yeah do
that in Palm Desert the polesco playing
rapper and ferocious it's time to make
an executive decision and break away
from the Magnus Carlson show as he has
not run away with the tournament let's
let's go with farouza Fabi what do you
think that's going to be our key match
and Anand is playing dukesh do they also
Napa we've got some backup but uh well
we know one player who's really anxious
to get it the the round started there's
alireza farouza our grand Chester
Champion by the way from 2022 and
um
outside of Magnus uh Miro just tell me
who has the best Blitz score in the
tournament thus far
I would think Yan nipponishi
I was going to say I thought it was for
rusia but we're not sure I think after
today no he lost to nepo and then he
barely drew his last games he was doing
very well but today something has
changed all right and maybe nepo
but a wonderful crowd for a weekend
Sunday uh Croatia
hosting
the grand chest tour and a big thank you
to our sponsors once again the super
United Foundation the Croatia full of
life foundation and thank you for your
sponsorship as well as to the St Louis
chess club you make our lives here so
wonderful thank you to all of our
sponsors for this marvelous event this
historic event as round 13. underway
C4 four Knight F6 and it looks like
Catalan if future plays D4 well we see
D4 B2 B3 no d2d3
b2b3 has also become well I'm not going
to say all the rage but yes
um b2b3 as as well as you said the
Catalan with D4 now this move Knight C3
that's really encouraging D4 I if I'm
black I've I start to think I should be
punishing my opponent for playing the
move Knight C3 and allowing A5 is a
quite a rare move like normally plays C5
or B6 in that position up to D3 exactly
I'm more familiar with B6 myself but
okay
um
exposition
feels like white well I don't know uh no
I don't think it how is white supposed
to get an advantage against this very
very solid looking setup
to provoke black to push D4 or C5 and
and then start playing so maybe oh there
we go E4 well here I here I would be
inclined to capture and maybe play
Knight to C5 eyeballing the D3 square is
a potential I can play Knight E5 here
Knight to E5
okay
um A4 followed by Queen A5
I I'm thinking uh takes on e4 uh or
takes on C4 and Knight C5 marrow where
would you uh be placing the black pieces
of the V4 you're asking right yes yeah
it's I know the answer yes black has to
brush up on his tactical skills and go
D4 which seems to be hanging a pawn but
if it's taken it's easy right right and
yeah so there's not such a sophisticated
tactic but what's interesting is
according to the machine it's the only
way or rather was the only way to keep
the position balanced and after the move
he has played Knight to H5 you just drop
the bishop back and White's quite
substantially better really
I wouldn't have kept oops sorry I'm just
going Knight H5 just Bishop E3 and
substantially better
I wouldn't have guessed that
Bishop we have Bishop E3 on the board so
now
Fabi has to deal with the pawn on D5 so
maybe take on C4
and then maybe E5
okay so take on e4 take on e4 and now
e6e5
yeah but then why did we put our Knight
on H5 because aren't we encouraging
no the opponency forest oh yeah good
thank you for that reminder yes
so tapes on e4 D takes e and E5 I guess
Federal just considering Knight takes E4
which would live the pawn on D3 as a
backward Pawn but not for long right we
can always push D4 yeah but Knight takes
E4 Knight back to F6 I'm not feeling
like I'm in too bad a shape
uh I'm I'm a little bit worried about
takes
E5 Knight E1 and the fight over the C5
Square starts to flare Anew 91 oh he did
take on e4
okay so on Knight F6 maybe he wants to
just take and push D4
fair fair
five immediately E5
let's probably want to play a five next
move I I I'm I'm finding myself drawn
tonight takes E5 Knight takes E5 Queen
takes H5
Knight takes D3 Knight E3 looks very
risky very risky right and then I get
the Rook on D1 well farouza said wait a
minute isn't there a tactic what did you
say marrow you gotta brush up on your
tactics yeah something on these lines
by the way Knight to G4
that's a sneaky move look your queen on
H5 is about to be trapped pay attention
G7 G6 could turn the tables
here Bishop C5 oh Bishop C Bishop C5 I'm
gonna well first of all I want to
sidestep Knight takes E3 if you play
Knight takes E3 you've got compensation
I was looking at Bishop G5 but then
there's F6 right and you're still in
trouble yeah but the move Bishop C5 kind
of forced right because what we want to
do is trade and give our Queen the C5
Square
uh
so now in G6 we have an in-between move
Bishop B7 Queen E7 and queen C5 and
because the queen would be rescued
uh with Queen C5 that's why Fabi played
F5 takes takes I think it's time to play
Queen G5
still I'm I'm a little bit worried that
the queen might end up trapped over
there so that's why uh I'm I'm inclined
to play the move Queen G5 as white yes I
like Queen G5
exchange of course maybe Queen to E5 but
okay
um it's a pawn first of all white is a
pawn up and secondly you know you're the
one who Fabi Fabi has taken
responsibility I want to say with the
move F7 F5 is uh exposed as a king a
little bit in the light Square Bishop on
C8 is not
happy we have Queen G5 Queen before on
the board Fab is going after the B2 Pawn
okay but he a three Queen takes B2 the
Knight could post up on that very nice
D6 Square and you want to take on C8 not
really I just want to annoy you by by
being by being on D6 he didn't he just
dropped his Knight back to C3 Knight C3
he's a three Queen takes B2 I'm sure he
wants to play Rook C1
which he has done by the way again
certain things are
not fully harmonious in right Black's
position either right
H3 Rook E1 something lands on E7 and
you're not going to be happy
like just
but who is it's there it's there it's
it's annoying us truly uh something to
be said for d45
starting with H3
that's a good start
if Knight E5 then Rook F to D1 because
we still can't play D4 yet I'm still a
little bit curious about how Queen E7 27
rookie eight Queen D6
nothing's hanging trying to stay in the
business but yeah nothing is hanging at
the moment
by the way how are the clock times of
the player oh he arusha's down to 35
seconds
35 no it's just 30 right Abby has more
than three minutes oh that's huge a huge
advantage on the clock for Fabi
absolutely
Queen E3 but we know feroza is an
amazing bullet player so true that
the position is complicated it's um not
clear exactly how white should continue
well the move Queen D4 is awkward as it
looks it does defend the Knight on C3 so
it makes Rook B1 followed by Rook takes
B7 a threat now I I admit I'm a
materialist F2 F4
reminds black that there's a hanging
Bishop on D7 as well Bishop C8 covering
both threads I like it
uh we're hearing updates that both nepo
and Magnus are dominating in their games
okay
our wish is playing good cash by the way
Bishop C8 as you've suggested taking
both threats away Rook B1 as well as F4
so Rook to E1 gift me the Knight the
Knight drops back to B7 now we're
chasing the queen
to G5 if needed
sorry three yeah
he's getting out of Dodge huh but it's
true
after D1 in G5 again 20 seconds the the
clock times are are
greatly in
the face favor yes yeah oh should he
play G5 now I think it's a perfect time
to go G5 because future has no time
so you you like uh blowing up the
position when your phone is down on the
clock uh the move F2 F4 I think was
designed primarily to stop Knight G5 and
I guess in this particular case give his
Queen a retreat Square uh it still feels
to me like if I'm white I'm kind of
happy on a good day if I can play C5 D4
D5 yeah that's that's looking good yeah
I think probably should have gone for G5
maybe a missed opportunity Knight A4 now
black looks passive
and fairuzia with no time on his clock
is coming up with some nicer ideas that
that maneuver Knight C3 to C5 I like a
lot on C3 the Knight was vulnerable on
C5 it's doing something he's putting
pressure on Pawn on B7 exactly
and it's it's getting easier and easier
for white to play I was about to suggest
another concept the bishop F1 I want to
play Rook E5 and the idea of putting a
Pawn on D4 in The Rook on E5 is
attractive Knight E3 provoking A4 give
me the pawn he can go back to C5 yes
another uh Target and we're just getting
a
Constantine is not having the tournament
that he'd hoped for Richie won his game
his game
oh we're going to an end game now
I looked away for two seconds exactly
but D3 is hanging what what am I missing
oh yeah it is hanging Queen D3 and he's
happy goes for it oh 95 five seven
seconds for firoza that's yeah but what
a strange trade
wins again against Anand wow
wow wow beating your Mentor your teacher
and your hero
and by the way nepo Nepal one was one
with black pieces
having a very very nice trip closer and
closer to Magnus
except Magnus may have wanted yeah he's
still playing but he is winning so okay
but uh for nepo this is a very very
welcome return to the top
and we do have a result you know what's
fascinating why we have four games
finished black won all four games it's
been a black blackish day Knight D6
oh wow three seconds
and by the way Knight C4 was a big
threat that was a four oh Queen after
was not a good move but who can blame
him he has one second on the clock and
he's just doing well now he's five and
that's very very very important a five
is hanging by the way there is a Pawn on
F5 but I can play Bishop D3 Maybe
he has gone for the bishop D3 but three
seconds
Chevy four is coming
yeah it was important to get off of that
pin the move King H1 does set up for
Bishop takes E4
oh this is not easy stuff for
not easy play for for uh at all good
Queen B3 oh G3 is hanging Shaq and queen
E1 just in time to defend the G3 pawn
and pose whoa Queen takes G3 and there
is a rook hanging on E8
yeah without that white was winning at
that point exactly oh my
so King G1
so what's going on now a Fab is just up
oh he's not up anything I thought he was
at the pawn he actually ended up losing
the pawn but then winning back on G3
right now Knight F5 seconds
how does he do this consistently just
making a move with one second on his
clock I'll be caught up
on time also down to five seconds
I mean it looks very nice position for
black definitely oh but there's Knight
F5 in the position which is very tricky
well he's going after black skin please
put a bishop on G say oh
he's setting up a mating net with a Pawn
on H5 and the Knight on F5 and for Rouge
is turning the tables with seconds on
the clock looks at seven okay if I've
been managed to get the Rook on the last
rank but still very dangerous
seriously and we could seconds
you could have taken that on E8
two extra pawns but you're just barely
uh holding the position
but how do we Checkmate oh he's allowed
the double attack and C5 winning with
the check huge blunder as Fabi
fighting for the second place
fat black wins wow
and the Jeep
GC points as well and farrugia
well come on that was self-inflicted
wound because he had like 30 seconds to
three minutes you can't do that at this
level bad clock management by the
world's number one rated Blitz player
there uh Miro I'm just getting reports
that black won every game
uh yeah you are not wrong
in the expert opinion of if I brilliant
co-host Nazi as you may have guessed
there have been a lot of ups and downs
in this ups and downs in this game right
so I just want to quickly pointed out
the moment where ferrugic would have
really you know seized the advantage so
Bishop C5 F5
captured there and for whatever reason
Knight G5 wasn't played and wasn't even
like seriously considered it would seem
so but Knight G5 was working and then
after age six you just dropped back
and yes the queen looks a little bit
shaky but cannot be trapped and white is
joining with like rookie one and yeah
gets close to decisive Advantage but one
thing that you have to see that after
G7 G6 and it's very important you have
to find an intermediate Rook to E1
and if you find this then white is much
better because now Queen G7 Queen H4 H6
and you have Knight to E6 you don't have
to go back to F3 and this is well
computer has this as absolutely winning
for white
so there was one moment and then okay
just quickly
I want to mention one game
of one Magnus Carlsen right Magnus
Carlsen defeats Ivan sarich it wasn't an
easy game
so they've played they've played the
karukan defense and up to some point I
think it was a was a theoretical game
Knight to A3 is not very common
9283 Bishop to H7 Knight C2 so white
tries to bring the Knight to E3 or in
case of C5 this Knight gets to D4 it's
exactly what has happened in the game so
Knight C to D4 A7 A6 because Bishop B5
is in fact quite annoying Bishop E3
Knight to G6 black has to develop the
bishop C4 once again very logical trying
to open up the position while black is
still uncansled D takes Bishop takes
Bishop to E7 and this computer has as
much better for white so Magnus is in
trouble after 14 moves or rather would
be in trouble would white find H to H4
why is that
a pawn sacrifice if the pawn is taken
then white goes with some sort of weight
captures here I think yeah after H4
Knight has to take yeah Knight takes
Knight takes Bishop takes and then white
starts the attack with Queen G4 g7's
hanging there is no comfortable way of
protecting G7 let's say Bishop G6 white
captures only six and the bishop is
hanging so that's very unpleasant and
just in few more moves so he played
Knight B3
Knight A4 and here was still possible to
play so sarich was indecisive and then
he sacrificed the pawn and it turned out
there is absolutely nothing just a bone
up for Magnus and he went on to win this
one and I think we have more analysis
coming up with anastasian Christian from
Zagreb
well I have to say the battle for second
place is definitely heating up we see a
Nepal we see Fabi uh tuning up their
engines and you are watching uh nepo's
game on Assassin let's start with that
one I did and actually it was a very
interesting opening I think he can
Inspire some other players by allowing
everything it was for white you know he
played Knight F6 and then castling you
know you can push a five you can push H4
and this is what the young sister did
and it looks very scary for black yes
and there are C5 and one more Pawn let's
give a pawn and then after a couple of
moves he also plays B5 so I was really
inspired by by this opening choice and
actually black got quite an interesting
position and he played very very
energetically this game I must say so
like look after all this move he started
to produce something on the Queen's side
he took actually he allowed him to have
these two pawns but that doesn't matter
he's still trying to create
he's getting attacked on the king side
it seems like but he never managed to do
so and yet you're better as black yeah
and yes and computer is quite happy with
Black's position all the way except
couple of moments yes so we're young
sister maybe could have played something
more decisive but it's Blitz right so
try to find out
I think just it fits nepo style you know
this type of complex this complicated
positions which he plays very well with
um this short time control and so look
there were a couple of moments here he
played this move Rook C8 and then uh he
decided he gave up this exchange that's
so nice actually and again look at the
position once again exchange down uh
pawns at least the bones are the same
but you know two plus spawns seems to be
quite dangerous but they're not you know
he decided he managed to create again
lots of threats now Queen F2 is the
thread and the funny thing is if you
play Rook of one maybe it was the best
choice already there is Knight F2 move
and then Queen is three oh that's right
with the seat most probably it's just a
draw but still no this is good no it's a
good sweating yes yes okay so I mean
there were some great ideas so that's
why white made this little bit
artificial move king of one and once
again some problems with development and
after a few moves uh look what he did he
managed to take one more Point actually
at this moment one of the best moves
here was just somehow to move the bishop
to the other diagonal and try to to
create some more sets on F2 but never
mind this is very logical and so after
that never managed to win this position
very beautiful one and I just give you
the update on this big clash between the
two Indian players and Gucci and I'm
only going to go to the critical moment
because it was good cash who was
pressing the whole game but at some
point he uh let Anan off the hook at
this point Anan had this move Queen to
B2 which would have created this tension
on the long diagonal it would have given
him enough compensation for the pawn
unfortunately he missed it he took the
pawn back but after Knight to G4 he's
just getting mated on the dark squares
E3 and after this one is just pretty
much over you take I give you a check I
give you another check I pick up the
bishop and that's game over another huge
Victory foreign
let's take a look at the standings after
this round incredible round by the way
only victories for black in this one and
still Magnus
Authority
20 points and as I was mentioning it's
hitting up Fabiano 19 and a half only
half a point alibraza losing some uh
steam some ground in the battle for
second position difficult loss against
Fabiano yeah is getting close now that
he won against vishan and he's on the
fifth place
big big matchups coming up your way in
the next round but before that we're
going to go on a short commercial break
and we'll be back shortly stay tuned
[Music]
it's time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
Young Junior Phenom ABI Manu Mishra and
returning senior Champion Alexander
shabalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also in include
over 2 000 chess lectures for anyone to
enjoy become a member and enjoy perks
such as free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
foreign
just had that big slip up uh losing to
Fabi but tell us about the pairings
coming up
let's take a look we have two pre two
former world champions playing each
other Carlson against the nun yeah when
the Legends play you gotta watch
and go cash against Fairuza it's
Carolina playing Le palesco Rockford
against Duda and the publisher playing
sorry we've got to do uh We Gotta Give
nepo a Little Love I mean after all he
is in second place so we're gonna have
that as our backup game we'll look at
Magnus and Bishi as our Marquee matchup
as we're getting ready for uh round 14.
Miro uh try to sum up what we've
witnessed thus far oh well once again
Magnus is not winning not winning a game
of the game of the game anymore but he
keeps this three points distance between
him and Nepal and what's even more
interesting I think like one leaping
over the other but Nepal and Fabi are
still within the zone
3 is a little bit back but yeah it's all
between nepo and far before the second
it seems
yeah they do seem to be kind of uh leak
frogging one another there but uh
that game that we just watched uh
farouzia uh I'm still amazed at how well
they play with just seconds on their
clock because I think so many players
would have collapsed instantly uh yeah
when he had King on H2 exactly pieces
over there yeah and he just kept playing
at uh nearly saved it until he Blender
at the very end C5 exactly
and here we have our GCT standings uh
coming into this event
so Wesley so is still in the lead but uh
this is fabi's second event exactly and
he can definitely take over I'm
expecting Fabi to pick up at least 10
points could potentially be more due to
we'll certainly pick up some but not as
many as well you might have wanted
and we have uh the GCT events that are
coming up they're going to be
it will be single cup unfortunately all
good things must come to an end this is
going to be our fifth and final show of
this fantastic event in Zagreb and we do
want to get in some thank yous and to
shout out to so many people who made
this event possible our sponsors of
course but also to say to Rex a
geniusing field here in the club Tony
Rich and joy Bray Rebecca Emily everyone
at the chess club as well as the world
trust Hall of Fame thank you for
everything that you've been doing for us
and then Randy and the team from
spectrum and Kevin and everyone at
Silverback make this production Marcus
and Brian they're in Zagreb and of
course to our colleagues and to our
viewers we do it all for you as uh
they're underway and again we have the
queen A4 check a move that Vichy would
have certainly
been paying attention to E5 game we have
this right yeah or two rounds ago yeah
with 97 that was the kukash game and
that was that movie E5 listen
I see in the database there's a game
Carlson aronian from the last year this
exact same position and how did that
game continue minus one
continue
I got that part I I you moved he moved
he moved a little bit faster than I
expected on that one but yes uh did it
go C6 and queen E4 are we still in that
game still following Iranian here played
Bishop C5
which makes a lot of sense of course
kind of like a Budapest Gambit you'd
like to see the pawn coming to E3 so
after Bishop C5 and queen E7 you can
round up the peshki on the E5 Pawn
exactly how the game went E3 Queen E7
yeah and and F4 was played and then live
on Castle short and again this that the
players in that case would be following
Magnus as white yes versus Levon as
black
okay well definitely a variation that
Magnus will have some familiarity with
Queen E7 on the board and if you just
allow black to recapture the well just
as I was about to say if you allow black
to just recapture the pawn that's a very
comfortable equality and
well I'm liking black very much Knight
to G G6 here he played Knight to D7 okay
intriguing but
no I I think this is a bad decision by
Magnus I think Vichy uh has equalized
already
he went past equality oh really yeah I'm
actually preferring uh Black's position
by the way Bishop H4 check could be uh
an awkward move to me Magnus is saying
go ahead give me a check I'll walk to D1
to C2
intriguing
would you have given the check I I I got
my hand would have made it whether you
liked it or not right uh Mira would you
have given the check Bishop H4 check
absolutely would yes and Magnus would
Blitz out king he took in F3 apparently
well I still suspect that it might have
been prepared and your pessimistic
assessment of the position important to
inform you is wrong it is slightly
better and yeah and he's very confident
and if you think of it Magnus is known
to outplay vision and games constantly
so maybe it was you know a deliberate
decision because indeed after Queen E7
the most critical and that was the move
he played against Arun in esf2 F4 right
but that H3 is also playable okay pretty
surprising by the way
you play H5 and I kind of follow you I
don't follow G6 I mean I was thinking
that you're playing H5 in order to put
the pawn on H4 grab some space whatever
but G7 G6 okay in a very big surprise
and Magnus played the move G2 G3 taking
anticipating H4 would be met by G4 here
I want to play Bishop to G2 but I don't
want to say that to to allow Knight to
D3 so Bishop E2 or
Rook D1 or castles King F2 is what
Magnus shows
wow okay
this has to be some really highfalutin
prep because it's very hard for me to
guess the moves there
well rub it in like that
you're true you did you did get in the
Wii and I like that the Royal we we take
we we take full responsibility for our
commentary uh b2b4 okay
um
you go back gift me the pawn tell me why
it's pushing too far the pawns on both
sides of the board
yeah it does seem that way right Bishop
B4 I
I do have to see it also looks a little
bit attractive for sure Rook to C8
inticity okay Vichy allows his pawns to
be split he also has F5 ideas now that
Rook is clean proud of the king
okay this move indicates to me that hey
give me uh let me play G4 and F5 and
I'll show you who's boss Bishop B4
again back and forth yeah what's going
on uh how come I haven't already played
B take C6 I don't know if my if I had
already played B take C6 I'm comfortable
playing now still I think Bishop C3 Rook
C1
uh sorry Rook C1 Bishop C Oh you mean
taking season six
okay so take on C6
Bishop takes C3 Rook C1 huh
two black pieces hanging
I guess I'm not worried about anything
in particular
okay
you can start with Rook a to C1
and who's playing on which side
yeah
Rook h1c we were really close on this
one we knew a rook was coming to see one
we I
instinctively I didn't want to give up
my Pawn on H3 because I I really wanted
to be able to play the move G4 and F5 to
try to trap the bishop Bishop takes H3
man was that just the blunder she asked
the same question he said look I'm
afraid of the move G4 I'll take away G4
and I'll take the bomb
good deal
Agnes now looks like did I just wake up
on the wrong side there
Miro do you like it when your opponent
gives you that look of
I blundered you suddenly feel good about
it right absolutely like even if you
have Magnus in front of you right you
take this Pawn with a bit of hesitation
but if you see this look okay that's my
point now very nice very nice E4 E5
Magnus says okay I just gotta play
through it I blundered upon my bad but I
have to make a move Hikaru Shake in his
head because that you don't know then
you don't know if it means he made a
great move or a man move I know because
that head shake I once played uh Anatoly
carp off and he sacrificed a piece
against me and I was very very uncertain
to capture it or not
but then when I did capture it his face
turned brightly red I was like
okay that was very good uh Bishop E6
well it's time to try to equalize Bishop
F3 uh material equality I mean I meant
to say with Bishop F3 I'm surprised
Michael still hasn't taken on C6 yeah
that's incredible patience there oh I'm
into D3 yes hello
that's unpleasant for Magnus does he
have to take now Bishop C5 I hope not
because that will really cement the
advantage if I play King G2 and just say
Okay 93 93 Rook C2
plus it looks a little all your pieces
are hanging whoa B take C6 Knight D3
check King G2 Magnus wants to capture on
okay uh there was a
there was no Fork there the C6 takes B7
uh Vichy said I didn't want to see that
so now 93 Rook C2 Bishop F5 looks good
and then I have 94 just to kind of short
circuit that diagonal but there's Knight
E1 check oh hello
hello so Bishop F5 is very very strong
because I wanted to meet Bishop F5 with
94-bit Knight E1 check
getting me from behind
yeah why it is in trouble can Magno save
this
but he didn't play Bishop F5 by the way
he played Bishop A5
okay just suggesting his
well all day now now I have to actually
calculate something uh that's awkward
they're making us work yes
he played 94 but there was a knight E1
check
both players uh Mutual blindness there
but now
uh White has this beautiful D6 Square
now I feel it's compensation Rook B1
takes takes
no I think what white already has
sufficient composition exactly
I feel the same as well
um I mean this year for choice
still no question about that but I'm
feeling that okay I can take on E6 and
play Rook to C2 I've got the I've got to
take on D5 and B6 oh simple that it's
the simplest for it to uh
win back the pawn
take take and group takes A7 maybe white
slightly better in The Rook ending
I wouldn't disagree
Nepal is winning his game we've heard
and so is Fabi so nepo is playing second
place is still going on a fantastic
tournament
and by the way uh marrow uh why aren't
you telling us that uh Magnus of late is
really
uh keeping that Voodoo hex in the end
game
is
one take white is completely winning
take on plus six yeah you just take on
G3 you've got two connected pass balls
absolutely crazy and Vichy was a pawn up
and he was just like what am I doing uh
it's it's all gone wrong what are the
games going on let's jump
he's up against Constantine yes
oh but he has a crushing position extra
Pawn dominating
pieces
yeah they should be over soon
and time wise 30 seconds against four
seconds
when it rains it pours huh and night is
coming to F5 with a check so
uh no Queen E7 what what happened the
first second there we thought Magnus
might lose and then 20 seconds later he
wins that was crazy that was you just a
whole series of just wonderful moves by
Vichy uh
yeah that was really shocking
impossible to do oops
Bobby wants his game
nice so so far we have three decisive
results white one all three games
so we went from a blackout to a whiteout
yeah looks like that except for Russia
is wow look at his position
look at this pawns that is a gorgeous it
almost looks like a a game of Space
Invaders here as black spawns are just
marching up the board
and go cash playing with four seconds on
the clock
but yeah the black she's completely
winning
they have more material and a great
position wow I would have kept that
night on G5 but uh
Rook A8
night came somehow he
he found the the C5 Square more
attractive than the G5 Square that's
remarkable for me yeah from G5 f3h3
we're both under attack precisely
but black can do really anything
and
Jan Christoph Duda won against Richie
Rapport that was a big uh Victory with
the black pieces oh Bishop takes F3 and
yet another Pawn disappears
and we're gonna have a bishop
magnificent Bishop on C4 as well
I was wondering which pawns do we push
first
it's like f
3 they were all good right all the poems
are good now UL Rook wants to come to C7
and
this should be a very easy win after
Rook goes to C3 exactly and pawn goes to
E4 King goes to E5 nope King went to
Pardon Me E5 would have been met by Rook
F5 check now E3 check and
he's getting a queen
yeah
and that's uh I like the way you said
that he's getting a queen and he wins
and that's all the games and were there
any draws uh fill in the Gap they're uh
in terms of draws not too many yes no
they don't like they don't like to not a
single one for a second consecutive
round right and I just thought you know
if about ferrugia's game we could have
said philidor would have been proud
right in the in the final position I
want to drive your attention to the game
that went unnoticed a rehear drop word
against young Christian of doula because
I was thinking do that known to be very
good in Blitz right and he was
struggling beforehand but now he seems
like at least you know to score a few
maybe Comfort comforting wins anyway he
outplays Robert and this is the position
of the the somewhat extravagant opening
and we already used to that with Richard
rapper playing and here Robert
absolutely had to play G3 G4 so once
again black is dominating the queen side
so you really have to seek for
contemplate and instead he goes King H2
perhaps getting ready for G4 and then
after F5
it's a disaster tonight it's almost
trapped and why I brought up great names
of the past
to explain it we'll have to go like few
more moves and over here I thought the
names of it would have been proud We
with young Christian you know like a
nice blockading night in the center and
an extra pawn and so on and they've
played a long game but it never Duda
never given report a single chance
and there is one more game that I wanted
to check just quickly far be literally
stampeding over poor
so once again wow that that's one funny
opening line by the way against the
Sicilian you really can play B3 of the
E6 at some point was quite popular
okay
C4 Queen C7 and a mysterious to me move
H to H3 so almost like a waiting one
more waiting myth but what's the point
of this waiting that black doesn't have
a comfortable move himself because now
if Black Goes Knight F6 which is kind of
one of the most natural developing myths
that E5 and that's why you've played H3
there is no Knight G4 right B6 Bishop B2
Bishop B7 and they've gotten to some
sort of a hedgehog position where
right gotten here and in a normal quote
unquote normal Hedgehog the Knight would
be on D7 and now you have it on C6 and
the problem is that it white constantly
threatens Knight D5 to such an extended
to the police who decided to build an
idea
and you know if in the opening you have
to play like Knight to B8 and back to D7
that means something's completely off so
in 10 moves let's say or eight moves
from now the position look like this
Knight on F5 and D5 absolutely dominant
and we've seen the end of it right but
there was one funny moment I found it uh
yeah over here with farby yeah after age
four interestingly enough unnoticed by
both players Knight B6 would have just
crashed in a couple of myths uh instead
of that Fabi went with Bishop C1 but
still won the game quite convincingly uh
back to you guys in the studio thank you
uh Mero uh you guys in the studio World
Nasi tell us about the standings after
14 rounds of Blitz Magnus maintains his
three-point lead well done Johnny
punishes still in the second and Bobby's
still in the third and no big changes in
the top three
yes I know that the mix looks all the
same man let's catch up with Croatia
well I have to say one a crucial game
was the one between the two youngsters
kukesh and Ali brezza because they were
separated by only one point so if Gucci
would have won that one he would have
caught up with Ali Reza that didn't
happen alibraza extended his lead over
gukesh by two points and uh you guys
caught the end of it but Anastasia you
were looking at the middle game the
opening phase tell us a bit about that
yeah I was checking the game and I think
the critical moment came around move 20.
so when this position maybe you just
need to realize that black has no good
moves maybe just The Rook fd1 waiting
for a bit you know improving the
position and asking those questions like
where do you move with your king here or
let's say what is your next move so good
luck yes and actually G5 Pawn is always
a Target right in in some situations
yeah Castle maybe you have like five yes
or 95 I mean many different ideas but
gokish decided to play straight forward
and he he went to he decided to get this
exchange but look what happened there is
nice geometry here but once again he
could just take on G5 again better
provide probably with better chances but
he decided to go for rugby one look at
this nice geometry Bishop B6 and he won
actually The Exchange but the problem is
that after winning this exchange black
is better you know like it's easier to
play for blacks
exactly I mean this Bishops I mean also
dominating the board and um actually I
must say that firucha played it very
well I mean he this he just slowly
improved his position look at all these
manuals with Knight who moved all the
way to C5 you know so he found the best
Square for the night and then he
improved also bishop and Bishop F6 and
really it was very difficult to play for
um for why this position and then he
also too consciously look at this very
nice geometry again and then be sure
before very nice blow I also yes 94 and
it's a very stripping Fork right triple
four yes and then I like how the bishop
came back to the game look so it was
Bishop before before he went to B1 and
then he came back again Bishop before it
was really nice so if the seat doesn't
have a bit often so in any case this
position is much better for black and
alireza simply want it slowly step by
step yes so we saw the end yes it was
beautiful what did you check I was
looking at this game of Jan uh
nepomayashi versus Ivan sarich who once
again is struggling up to this point in
this event Jan definitely piling up
Victory after Victory and I have to say
he has to he's inspired I feel how he
plays actually he's pushing right now I
can I can can say so I mean I've got his
confidence I have to say I I think we
have five rounds perhaps he won at least
four of them 100 sure but I think he won
at least four of them definitely a good
day for him but also a good day for Fabi
at the office so they're both vying for
position for the second place which is
nice which is nice yes I mean we have
some competition yes absolutely we like
to see that and take a look at this
Beyond with white pieces Yvonne with
black pieces inviting this change very
early on this change of structure I
really like this idea C4 he's just
looking for him in the position very
early on I think this is uh this is the
main strategy yes yes I like the move d4
it looks a bit off because you're
closing up your Bishop but at the same
time you're also closing up Black's
bishop and you're most likely going to
go E4 and take advantage of your space
advantage in the center he decides to go
F4
Queen to E2 and I have to say uh it
looked like a very clean game by Yan
slowly slowly increasing his Advantage
it looks like you have some weaknesses
around your king but the bishopon G2 and
in fact the pawn on F4 covers a lot of
ground right a lot of important squares
you don't have a way to create any
problems and I have a clear plan that's
why expand on Queen side create
weaknesses and this is exactly what Yan
did take a look at this B5 take on D5
take on F4 Ivan was looking for some
counter chances it looks like he's
getting some confidence I was the king
with the queen at night next to the king
if there's no F1 Square your check made
it right
there is still F1 Square yes he did not
give a check he took on D1 and took on
E3 but after the pawn lands on C7 and
perhaps this is something that he missed
this is kind of all she wrote
um he allowed him even to take one of
two he doesn't care about the spawns yes
he just wants to push himself exactly
exactly if you take first of all I'm
just taking the Rook on E8 and that's
problematic but as you you were meshing
there is nothing around the king you can
take with the check but I'm just simply
going take it back maybe I can even go
into F1 look at this move and if you
take I get another queen hey give me the
queen back give me the queen back I need
to put it back on the board then you
take the room then I take on it this is
over nice and um in fact nothing
happened after that for black uh White
Jan just played a brilliant game I have
to say I really enjoyed this one from
start to finish it's one of the best
players in Blitz whenever it is in shape
yes exactly yeah nice back to you in the
studio as we get ready for the next
round thank you Anastasia thank you
Christian let's just take a quick look
at the pairings coming up for round 15
as I think we have number one versus
number two in the tournament right in
the Premiership playing Magnus Carlson
even if he wins he still can't catch him
yet but it would be a very great great
result for Napa absolutely that'll be
our Marquee matchup and sarich playing
rapper student playing carwana that'll
be our backup game in case of we have a
fizzle
and as we prepare for this uh upcoming
round uh Anastasia caught up with Richie
report I hope you like her interview
[Music]
Richard welcome to Croatia how did it
happen that you've never been here
before you were living not so far away I
guess oh yes uh yeah actually I was
always doing very close yeah I always
find this triangle around the aranzagra
but somehow I managed to to avoid this
so far yeah I don't know as you know
life always brings you to places so now
I'm here yeah yeah so here we are now in
Zagreb into what let's say your
expectations here in for this event and
in general in this grandchester
oh I'm I don't think I'm doing too well
in this adventure story on a cell and
look at your standings but like I had
some solid performances but I feel like
solid is not good enough in grantchester
terms so
um yeah again if I would if it were to
change here in Zagreb it wouldn't hurt
too much if I would have some really
good performance but as of expectation I
I don't really have any you know
spectacular expectations just trying to
play chess and trying to you know save
my use my remaining energy reserves and
see what happens here yeah we were
talking about
Serbia now and you were from Hungary and
now I think you live in Romania right
and you're going to play for the
Romanian team and what do you think
impact it had on your life and on your
profession as a Jasper to live in all
these countries have you got something
from each of this country of and each of
this culture yes and Croatia is next
here
sure yeah you know okay I was obviously
I'm born and raised in Hungary more or
less so
my even my especially my chess culture I
think is very much shaped shaped by that
um yeah then obviously I moved to Serbia
and I was kind of a young adult and so
therefore my my development as a person
I think it's very much shipped by
Western culture and and generally the
life in Belgrade I really enjoy it I
really like the atmosphere there so I
always recommend it for for people who
tourists who are found during what to
visit because okay it doesn't have such
a reputation as a touristic destination
but I feel like the the people are just
so nice it's it's compensated here you
know and now bucharesti abucharest is a
bit I'm I'm still unfamiliar with it in
a way because okay I'm very new there
I'm very new in Romania
um you know obviously it was kind of um
commitment from my part and I will see
how it will work out
um I'm still adjusting so yeah that's uh
that is unknown for now yes and um well
of course everybody's wondering that
you're still in touch with dingly Rand
and when what's happening with him after
the match and when we are going to see
him again let's say do you have any news
from him
I have as much news as the next guy yeah
so
yeah I sometimes feel very right to each
other but he's a very close guy and
I think he's he's you know
I hope he's doing what he likes to do
yeah let's put it this way that's the
most important actually to do what you
like to do in your life and actually how
do you find this balance between being a
professional chess player and trying to
do things which you really like to do
and have healthy life if possible yeah I
mean being a professional chess player
generally gives you this Freedom or
Illusion of freedom to have you know
let's say a Monday morning yeah when
everyone's at work and you just wake up
whenever you want to wake up and do
whatever you like to do right so it is
generally I think suits my expectations
from Life very well of course when you
go to a tournament and it's totally
different like for instance I'm here
talking to you right
not sleeping yes so okay it's kind of
balances itself out I guess at the end
um yeah so for me it's always been a bit
of a challenge to to balance it I guess
I've been playing uh maybe a little bit
too much for my standards enroll and I'm
already longing for for a break and uh
some small location but other than that
you know it's more or less fine yeah
only five days to go very exciting chess
I mean I wish you all the best of luck
and to still find some energy for
fantastic games you you play always
we're looking forward for it thank you
Richard thanks so much
[Music]
foreign
welcome back uh the importance of this
upcoming round it's showing in that
graphic Magnus all right the first and
second in Spanish playing each other
Magnus Carlson and Yanni publishing
Bobby's still in contention for the
second place because he's only half a
point behind Nepal and it was Fabby that
stopped the winning streak of Magnus by
making that early draw that extra half
Point well can yawn
and make it close this Magnus hasn't
lost any games in the blitz yet not not
at all and Miro jump in uh you had that
moment when vishi could have played
Knight E1 check right and put a big fat
zero as you said Magnus hasn't lost a
single game but he was that close like
unimaginable
against Vichy is that the one yes and
then yeah wait a second don't start
please don't start please
yeah Bishop A5 94 and how about this 91
Missy what what's wrong it's just it
wins in exchange it wins the game right
wow it was very close and Vichy knows it
too she's thinking about it right now uh
yeah he has that look of the man of the
player who carrying the baggage of the
previous round on his uh shoulders and
here's our Marquee matchup as b2b3
the bent Larson gotta take Magnus out of
the opening but the problem is Magnus
prepared against me three too
how do you like that that almost looks
like one of those one minute bullet
games where the players have pre-moved
right e3g3 G6 and you win a run and
usually you promote Bishop right away
exactly E4 F4
Miro uh is aggressive that it can get
that's
is a real shock for me E4 and F4
is that no that can't be it is a theory
and no no notably there is one game from
1992 played between Sophia and Judith
Folger believe it or not
wow uh first of all I would say after E7
E5 I like to play Black like I'm just
feeling I'm better with black after like
five moves you know like no I I'm really
really surprised it takes Knight G4
so the idea of all of this is the fact
that White's King is still in the center
E3 a little bit tender
um and play Queen E2 here
just wow Queenie too just looks awkward
right Queenie two Knight C6 and it feels
like at least for me uh that uh black
has an early initiative and well that
whole sequence with F4 and E4 is not
it's boomeranged I want to say against
nepo at the moment Knight G4 and nepo's
in a think tank
an indication that something is wrong
Knight D2 ignoring Knight E3 is a
possibility okay I'd probably play
Knight C6 although I'd really think
about Knight E3 long and hard that looks
like a really good move you're gonna
have to play Queen C1 and it's funny to
see these guys in trouble after move
seven
something wrong with that with the white
pieces 86 now Queen E2 trying to make
amends Knight takes E5 again it just
feels like
so now a knight F3 rookie eight right
um
sometime earlier in the tournament mural
you were telling me that
nepo is playing a king's Gambit and if I
saw this position you know something
about this King it has features of a
king's Gambit I'll put it like that
again I I still like magnus's position
for a good reason yes and Marcus is
winning he's with the winners
yeah and uh well we have Queen G5 check
getting out of uh the uh the discovery
G4 coming or yes how is he winning yes
prescription before I have Queen do too
so I'm assuming King B1 here King B1
just take on E5
oh okay
in B1 take on E5
followed by Bishop G4
yeah
this is how we move uh 15. and nepo
looking to the side looking at scants
like why did I this is ugly
like like I like like
how do I get myself out of here Bishop
takes E5 and it'd be too late to figure
out how to get out of this well first of
all you material down rookie five you
don't have you don't need to play Bishop
G4 your your material down and you're
under attack so black has the
compensation as well Queen C4 uh
inviting B5 by the way
B5 how can
can I take on C7 no I don't think so
I've been Rook C8 looks looks pretty
vitamin C6 Maybe you know I I almost
over did it there I almost I want to
play Rook C5
but uh Rook C5 Queen takes C5 and my uh
intended Discovery has a drawback Bishop
C2 Queen C2
um B5 this might be a very quick game
and again I mean Magnus leading by three
points nepo playing very very well we
were anticipating a huge
clash and it's a one-sided Affair a
terribly one-sided Affair at the moment
Magnus is going to have to blunder badly
to allow nepo back in the game I like
the Moon from d8 I liked uh B5 as well
but it just feels very one-sided at the
moment because whether I take on d8 or
go Bishop D3 I'm gonna lose another Pawn
yeah G2 is hanging too
by the way with Victory Magnus would
clinch because again he came into the to
this round with a three-point lead and
that headshake of Napo just says it all
Bishop
if Magnus wins this game he would win
the tournament three rounds in advance
yes
wow yes
yes uh by the way B5 on the board now
so it's all going his way uh Bishop 2017
there's Rook C8 as before and we're
going to see that and I think it's
resigns Queen takes E7 Rook C8 Bishop on
E2 is hanging Pawn on G pardon me Bishop
on E2 is hanging upon on C2 is hanging
with a check uh I guess when it rains it
pours a mirror this is this is a
disaster and there's the there's the
handshake let's jump to our game between
Duda and afabi
their discussing but yes uh doodle fobby
wow do we have Duda has a lot of extra
oh just one pawn it looks like he had
more
one two three four five I'm still
counting how did you do that Alicia's
told me okay
taking a
advice from here get it uh two Bishops
um this looks really bad from five
because his night is completely out of
place
yep
I think that that's good because
and you can post up to Rook C1 Rook C5
and by the way uh just to confirm uh we
wanted to wait to get that confirmation
but yes Magnus has won the Croatia
super United rapid and Blitz our
champion forty thousand dollars richer
our congratulations to Magnus and for
one of the most extraordinary
performances
we've ever witnessed a perfect 9-0 in
day four and after today he might become
world number one in Blitz as well in
live ratings let's see there's still
more rounds but he has a chance to
overtake Fury
somehow with all of the accolades that
was the least I was expecting that you
know he gains
30 points 30 rating points no I'll take
the check
nice uh Bishop takes G5 Knight F6 and
uh
when you think about the rating points
just two more victories and he'd be 2900
900 class
that's that's pretty good achievement
that's a that's extraordinary actually
and uh so now the other players are
definitely only playing for the second
place yes and I think there's only
well Fabi and nepo are playing for the
second could firoza possibly catch them
I'm likely
well with nepo's loss and the potential
of fabulous in this game and if ferrusha
wins his he actually has a chance and he
wants your choice I'll give you uh I'll
give you credit where credit is due
Bobby was miro's choice and uh
you you you guys are
fine okay yeah
um Duda by the way he impressed
me so greatly in Warsaw where he and
Magnus were dueling one another all the
way to the finish line and due to almost
caught Magnus at the very end I'm sure I
expected more from Judah I'm sure he
expected more from himself 15 and a half
points at the moment uh
a victory in this game uh we'll get him
some GCT points well it's okay I think
we underestimate how tired these players
can be I think Dura has been playing up
so in Non-Stop for months has he yeah
yeah I so sometimes uh the players I
think it was some somebody pointed out
to me that Hans Neiman had been playing
like 60 games in two months it was just
you know non-stop indeed uh oh by the
way beautiful moves first of all the
inclusion of A4 a little bit a little
move that secures as a a protected past
Pawn that was big and then now dude is
up three Pawns
you were waiting to say that
three bonds uh that sounds like a lot
Miro three pawns yeah his position is
winning already for quite some time but
now there is like literally zero chance
for Fabi and Rook C1 Rook C6 I was
saying a post-up some time ago but that
looks really really good uh what is he
waiting for and a little updates Richard
won his game with a checkmate
again Steve I'm sorry okay that's a
rarity we haven't seen many checkmates
people usually resign right they're too
fast they do get in that resignation
quickly
um again Rook C1 uh and Rook C6 and I
think Fabby would have to throw in the
towel once we see that and it's just too
compelling no counter Play No chances
for black he's trying he just play out
of five but Queen just steps back and
queen D3 yeah
I wonder what was the opening that gave
Bobby such a bad position or maybe he
made a mistake in the middle game later
on
whatever it was this is so so bad I mean
it's almost like put your
throw in the towel Rook C6 is on White's
agenda as it is Bishop G5 as is G takes
F5 full disaster and for and unfolding
here for both of you Fabian I put this
round has been a disaster truly
uh Rook f8 again the move Bishop G5 but
Rook C6 how how can you not play Rook C6
and Duda has played it yeah
amazing oh and now Black's King is
completely open as well
again when it rains it pours right
uh Shack now we
I'm six seconds for coffee
no do Bishop C5 looks good Bishop C5
looks excited Queen G3 right I was
wondering also Bishop G5 Rook A4 Queen
G3 that type of thing you're just
setting up checkmates
by the way we have a con we have a pass
Pawn as well if you forgot about that
Rook takes H3 Queen B5 or B7 right away
yeah despite Queen C2
and somebody's flag fell either flag or
Fiber resigned not sure
and feruja won his game against danand
do we have any remaining games again
this players are just not making any
draws
Constantine and gookash let's jump in
and see what's going on between these
two Gladiators big surprise but
wait I thought Constantine was winning
wait a minute Rook F1 not anymore
there's a Checkmate on H1 and there goes
an exchange and suddenly googesh
is open exchange but that sea Pawn is
still pretty dangerous
do that
and both players under 10 seconds
easy to blunder for both sides
yeah I think White's King is safer now
by the way there was a chance there when
Constantine could just have played the
move C7
96 oh he didn't play Knight E6
Knight B5 looks good and then I maybe I
can get in 96 but
okay he's this is this position is full
of tactics and neither of them have any
time to calculate I mean probably the
computer will be telling us it's a win
for black but I tell you I see three
results with that pawn on C7 no that
pawn on C7 is a massive maybe black is
the offended Rook takes C7 on tap Rook
takes C7 oops yes okay
and that was huge the clock times again
wait what happened oh the police go
flagged wow
a very very relieved gukesh there at the
very end as he maybe dodged something of
a bullet uh Miro fill in the gaps of
another version uh well the Pulaski he
was one move away from winning this game
oh oh well still hasn't scored a single
win
well um really really limited on time
this time so just quickly highlights of
the games with of the game between
alireza and Vichy so it all started here
well already quite complex but
relatively balanced position and alireza
is going to sacrifice a night B takes B
takes black gets the chance to run away
with his horsey e takes F6
h7h6 because Knight G5 was threatening
and then white goes C5 here and and
should have gone Knight to C4 after
which apparently black would have better
chances Knight D5 and queen D4 and then
up to the point they play with computer
Precision Knight B8 tries trying to get
on C6 Knight C6 Queen A4 Knight A7 and
really was such a sharp game just look
at this picturesque position so both
Queens are attacked Knight F7 Bishop C2
nobody's taking nothing Bishop D5 almost
like you know Mikhail talo was
reincarnated C7 C6 Bishop C6 mistake
from firuja are not absolutely had to
take the Knight on F7 after which we are
getting a crazy position like this and
then white even can consider capturing
the bishop when he's a rook down but
black still has like all the pieces
hanging and so on yes and Vichy missed
this one he went Bishop B3 after which
Bishop takes King takes Bishop F3 black
is up a piece for a lot a lot of Pawns
and we already seen in the previous
round how good Fury is was a bunch of
Pawns that he didn't really give vishi
any chance all right and then to
continue with some analysis let's go to
Zagreb Croatia with Cristiano
yes so we were checking the game of
Fabiana Quran against Yankton it was a
very important game for this round we
were still fighting for the second place
and you saw that you caught the last
seven minutes of the game and Christian
what happened before where Fabi lost the
track well I have to say it probably
went bad early on for Fabiano out of the
opening it just didn't feel like he has
a very good position uh we saw the
trumpovsky C5 this is a very aggressive
way to play with the black pieces at the
same time it felt like Duda did uh take
a very um impressive approach to his
opening stance Bishop to F5 Knight to F3
and this was a big mistake for Fabiano
E6 allowing the move Knight to H4
um you're not supposed to allow this
because after Bishop to G6 and this is
what we've seen all throughout the game
he was just struggling to find any sort
of counter play on the light scores it's
bad it never got any better and
unfortunately for Fabiano he couldn't
take advantage of the fact that Magnus a
bit his direct rival for second pair
place
he was happy and actually he doesn't
need even to show up for the next round
because he has already won the
tournament congratulations to a Magnus
we will be taking a short break in fact
we will let's take a look at the
standings as we are entering the final
three games we see Magnus has already
won the championship four points ahead
so impressive that's it absolutely
impressive and Fabiano caruana still
vying for position for second place
alibreza Awards
yes absolutely we're going to go on a
short commercial break we'll be back
with round seven in just a few minutes
stay tuned
thank you
Yvonne is I'm glad to see you once again
in Croatia you're playing for the third
time already and this event attracts
lots of crowd here I mean many people
come for the to the plane hole to watch
you especially playing uh does it give
you extra motivation uh yes but also
gives extra pressure as well so as I
said for me this is one of the most
important tournaments in a year because
I play with the strongest players in the
world
and I'm trying to do my best and
you know make make myself
[Music]
shown in the best possible way uh
considering the chess part and
yeah it also it's the strongest
tournament in Croatia and that's why I
always attracts a lot of people to watch
and also the the best players in the
world are here so I guess all of this
matters yeah do you think chess is
getting more and more popular in Croatia
how do you feel yeah I think in general
in the world it's and it's same in
Croatia in last couple of years
mostly thanks to this online boom I
think just is becoming way more popular
than it used to be
and
I like where this trend is going so far
yeah that's definitely goes this way and
I remember you playing last year in this
event you had so many winning great
positions and I remembered you spoiled
many of them but still you showed your
strengths and that you're able of course
to fight with all chess players here my
question is did you try to change
something in your prep in your approach
to this event and I know that you had
this camp together with one forest and
also some other regions how did it go uh
well this Camp wasn't so intended for me
but I always like
to go there and enjoy just playing some
some just before this event
about my losses from the previous year
yeah it was tough messing up so many
winning positions or losing the Drone
positions uh this this year I'll try to
be a bit more focused
in the time trouble uh since I think
that's my weakest part of the game when
I'm like
down
let's say one minute and less I start to
play very very badly and
I'm hoping that this year I will improve
that that aspect of the game yeah for
sure I mean good luck with that and my
last question is you know in 2021 2022
there were there was a different field
this time we have many new players and
whom I looking forward to play against
the most
uh well usually I like to play against
Magnus since that's always
uh how to say
I forgot the word the right word in
English
yeah challenging exactly you know what I
mean
and
besides I think I've already played with
everyone else in the field many times so
I know the players as well
and uh actually last year it seemed like
very strong yeah so this year
it's similar but uh
it a lot depends of my on my form and
whether I will be
I'll be able to to convert good
positions yeah if I reach them yeah
that's great all the best of luck for
you in the tournament thank you very
much
[Music]
it's time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
Young Junior Phenom ABI Manu Mishra and
returning senior Champion Alexander
shabalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the Arts culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
foreign
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American cop as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
foreign
welcome back everyone as we have our
standings after 15 rounds of Blitz
please do the honors message Magnus
Carlson extended his lead and actually
winning the tournament three rounds
ahead our congratulations to Magnus all
he had to do to do that was win 11 in a
row well done well done indeed and in
second place at the moment
Shea and only half Point behind Fabiano
caruana said Russia with still some
chances to finish second absolutely and
tell us about the pairings for round 16
coming up
let's take a look
we have I think Magnus is playing firoza
that's a huge game for uh and of course
again our champion Magnus Carlson forty
thousand dollars richer but he will go
away from this event thinking about that
streak of 11 consecutive wins sorry so
Carlson is playing field Roger that will
be our K match uh Anand is playing
against Duda karuana sarich and Rapport
Nepal machine that will be a backup game
very very nice
and with Magnus taking the 13 GCT points
what gc2 points are available for our
second and third and fourth place
finishers so they're fighting for 10
points eight seven and so on yes
precisely so
right and that is uh why that game
between gookesh 2 by the way and Duda is
very important because that's a half a
point gap between the to as they are
playing in this uh round 16 sorry for a
moment there I forgot what round number
it was it was like because Magnus won
with four rounds to spare that's so
extraordinary uh it's like the
tournament's over thank you all for
coming goodbye
we'll wrap things up right here right
now but no we've got four more rounds to
go Magnus Carlson versus ferrugia I'm
very curious about how they do against
one another in their head to head
because once again coming into the
tournament Borussia was world's number
one as far as Blitz players are
concerned and there you see him at the
board waiting for his well illustrious
rival
it's usually hard to play well when you
have nothing to play for meaning that
Magnus already won the tournament right
but in this case playing for second
third fourth Grand Chester points is so
crucial for alireza again he is the
defending tour champion and he wants to
get as many points as he can
as he returns to St Louis where he had a
dream
well Dream Events because he did the
rapid and Blitz
and this she kind of faded right mirror
right I think he started with the win
but then everything goes goes against
him it seems yeah missing Knight E1
against 91 check against Magnus was
particularly egregious that would have
won the game uh most certainly for Vichy
how do you recover from that missing 91
I know you just feel it and here we go
as Magnus starts with Knight F3
in this tournament we haven't seen
Magnus play in any crazy openings like
he did in uh Poland right he was playing
b5s and all kinds of all kinds of things
mixing it up he still has this
propensity at times to do something
right and commentators a little bit of
unusual off the Beaten Track but then
they transpose into the exchange slav
which has a very uh drawing reputation
C3 on move two
not a novelty
there's no way to avoid transposing into
slow battery C3
yeah now here's a question if I go
Knight F6 which he did not do uh Bishop
F4 would that have been a draw offer I
don't think Magnus would do that no I
but I don't think Ali Reza is interested
in in it either at this moment because
he's trailing nepo and Fabi by so many
points it's kind of like All or Nothing
yes
because I think he has the fourth place
probably more or less guaranteed right
so he has to go all in and try to win as
many games as possible in the last three
rounds exactly
I have to do that with black against
Magnus truly
uh now we might see Queen B6 after
Bishop G5
um F6
yes we have a six on the board and
Bishop goes back to D2
yeah this is uh
that it's a lot of chewing and throwing
with the bishop but the Knight is
offside so you more or less are going to
play a kind of a Dutch not a Dutch stone
wall but you're kind of provoked to
playing F5 I didn't like really playing
G6 my knight on uh H5 could get trapped
so F5 stops that
and well
if you want to be really annoying
Bishop to G5 that's kind of funny move
but I don't think
yeah I
why I need to start developing yeah I
think it's time just to go E3 and start
fighting for the E5 Square Bishop B5 and
Knight E5 uh certainly uh I would find
attractive E3 on the board if I'm in
black shoes by the way I'd probably want
to play A6 to avoid Bishop B5 and Knight
E5 so he's allowing it Knight F6 Bishop
D6 maybe would you still play 95 yes I
would with uh
with alacrity
speed get in that move 95
well hirosha player Bishop D7
exactly against 95 right
now
sure Castle six Bishop D6
maybe I should start playing the Dutch
yeah it's not injurious at the moment
but now we're starting to feel it okay
so the Knight comes to E5 and if you
take
this is one of those things where I
recapture and I find that the square D4
becomes really really like this perfect
anchor model Square
uh for the night uh castles on the board
feel that after Knight takes C6 things
are petering out but still the structure
advantageous for white it might take C6
B takes E6 Knight to A4 with the idea of
Rook C1
and maybe on a good day F3 Bishop back
just you're seeing a lot of arrows here
but uh I think you probably Knight E2
immediately
yes yes Bishop B5
uh very important by the way to get in
that move before white is quick with
Queen B3 and Bishop B4
three rounds are
see if any
Magnus can lose one game in the Blitz he
did lose one game in Poland right he won
yes 11. he had 10 and a half out of 11.
draw six something like that he lost one
yes
boy I mean something to celebrate and
then the 18 rounds of Blitz you beat
Magnus once and uh you know it's
headline news because right now I like
Black's position
foreign
yeah wait a minute just a second uh Miro
has Magnus given his opponent
he messed something up because wait a
minute Queen H4 is a massive threat at
the moment right those last couple of
moves 92 and rookie one were not the
best and now black seems to be better
and you have to play a really awkward
moves like Knight F4 Queen H4 Knight H3
and young black takes the pawn yuck or
White can simply play H3 and just give
up the E5 Pawn
yeah I think that's the way to go at
this moment H3 Knight takes E5 Knight F4
with the idea of Bishop C3 and try to
take your chances in the Bishops of
opposite of color well to avoid a little
bit Magnus could uh sorry firoza could
take on E2 first and then take on E5 so
it'll be Knight versus Bishop with an
extra Pawn
so on H3 Bishop takes E2 H3 Bishop E2
rookie 2 95 Bishop C3 yeah I mean it's
an extra Pawn it's a good Pawn why not
and he has done H3 did we see Bishop E2
yes
good call Nasi we are guessing some
moves well when they're forcing where
we're showing our understanding our
prowess
um
an extra Pawn uh farouja uh
dare I say it has the best position no
no what am I saying Magnus has actually
had some losing positions uh that he
also has two extra minutes on the clock
he has three and three minutes and 20
seconds against one minute and 20
seconds it was terrible clock management
that farugia had against Fabi which
ended up uh costing him the game uh but
with extra time
this is his best chance for sure could
have asked for more no A4 on the board
now it's a pause because
when you see when you're playing against
your opponent's bishop and your opponent
is putting their pawns on dark squares
you would like to
keep your opponent's pawns on dark
Square so it moves like B5 start to be
attractive
but in this particular case finding a
better Square for the night so you can
play Rook C4 also starts to be
attractive
black
Rook D2
oh we have different moves so Photoshop
played 97.
okay Rook C4
it's time
Rook C4 oh I think after Roxy four
Magnus will offer the queen trade Queen
E5
I will happily capture the queen and
capture the pawn on A4 you're not afraid
of Rook see don't go Rook C8 check
go go Rook CA check my knight is waiting
in Ambush so seven looks good enough
though
oh I was about to say don't go Queen A7
Knight C8 you might get ensnared in a
terrible oh why trade on white grade A
pawns Knight C8 wouldn't that have Queen
A8 was the only move
if Knight C8 exactly and then the queen
is well there right oh yeah and Knight
C8 and then maybe Rook F to C7 and
you're all you're all tied up and
everything
um
now
I feel this compensation strangely
enough
things okay you can go E5 Rook take C4
you have to take the first C2 Rook C2
and then maybe play H6 just so our King
always has an escape
useful useful uh B6 and Rook C7 is
something you might want to avoid if
you're black I don't think we can avoid
it but maybe we can prepare for it
group check
well let's see what a certain a certain
moment E5 is going to be a disturbance
right that's why I have four Blackness
to play F4 very quickly and try to get
something going on they
King side by the way uh Vichy and conson
ant in
their game Draw
it's so rare we're saying draw I think
we haven't had any trust in a while
truly uh five decisive games
oh and uh apparently Rapport is winning
against Nepal that's huge the fight for
second has been so close uh by the way
B7 B6 came with strange timing
because uh black uh farusia had the
choices of both E5 and F4 and now it's
Magnus saying okay I better trade Queens
otherwise my King's going to come under
attack sorry enough but what if I play
Queen B4
that's an excellent question
each eight is safe I'm not getting mated
and that's very very nice that's an
important point that the Knight is doing
a great job guarding the queen before I
guess Rook C7 let's have about 40
seconds now
exchanges the Queensland goes E5 okay
he's still a pawn up so he's got every
reason to uh
to think that
he's better but uh well I mean B6 is
very good indeed
um
looks trying to leverage because I don't
even have an idea f8
right no I'm just losing the B7 Pawn
yeah but there is a a passer right
but let's say
so if you go E4 for example I'll go back
to d8 if you take on B7 D3 is the issue
is in time I go D3 King E1 I go Knight
four
we have a trade
and Magnus
I'll win in the pawn right yes he did
yes
uh but
but if Magnus wins this game yes he
joins the 2900 Club
impressive impressive oh I love this
move Knight F4 that is a nasty move you
can't take the pawn on D4 there's Knight
E2 check in the meanwhile you can't play
King F2 either
because but he took B7 now and D3 and
how do you defend the pawn Rook D5
Rook D5 B7
D2 B8 T1 and then the whole other end
game oh my gosh but you're in a pin but
I can't take advantage of your king
seven seconds crazy Rook takes B6 no 72
so
we went from endgame to Middle game
again
how's that possible we we talk about
going from the opening to the ending how
do you go from the ending to the middle
game
never did say
people oh Magnus is blundered a bishop
but there was Queen E6 hanging he could
have taken the Knight
what yeah that was Queen E6 and Rook 61.
yeah now I just said will Magnus lose a
single game and yeah
wow yes he will well it's not a little
for fun
yeah uh clock time sorry uh Magnus is up
to 20 seconds feroz are still seven
seconds but he can definitely we catch
up very very nicely he's got so many
moves to catch up quickly Queen three
check King H6 just Safeguard your king
get in those checks
uh
yeah that was definitely a moment where
man takes E6 take in the night yeah but
he missed it
right
so now all farugia has to do is maneuver
his Knight to the G3 Square so Knight F4
Knight H5 or Knight f4 knighty2 on his
agenda of course you have to make sure
that you're not making an illegal move
to gain time on the clock true because I
always playing with just five seconds is
just enough Wrecking
if we if we go Queen G5
and go into the king and pawn end game
that's
it just depends on where our King is
right
it's fascinating that firosha has a
clear extra piece and it's still hard to
beat Magnus I know like that's just not
fair
uh by the way he's doing it in a very
very strange way the King was fine on
age six the queen was fine on F6 then
with the queen on F6 the King on H6 you
could have put the Knight on G3 and it
would have been just easily easily
winning I actually like bringing the
king more towards the center for black
can you will always be able to cover
with queen or the night true
hopefully now he's back to the ideal
setup with the queen on F6 and the
Knight just the Knight on j3 yeah he
just goes Knight H5
and
whoa he played that with how many
seconds on his clock very few uh gukesh
has won his game against Duda
yeah I think firoshi just needs to put
put the Knight on H5 right or in this
case put the queen on D5 and maybe take
on G2 okay we're getting close
yes
certainly are yes
or queen E4
it's running there's no way there's
Perpetual here right right Queen to D5
Queen 25 is the game yeah well
I can never call it with Magnus
uh by the way there is mate on G2 yes
check mate finally wow wow our
congratulations to farugia as one and
only who by the way back
denies him the 2900 class uh and then
the remaining game family yeah
if I be true and only when we had
besides feroza was kukesh wow
Miro uh catches up please fill the gaps
of this very eventful round as we see
Magnus becoming a human being again uh
right but he had all the chances to
remain you know even after this opening
which went absolutely wrong and so on he
managed to seize the advantage once
again so indeed the move that Nazi was
mentioning King to F2 would have could
have been like almost winning for white
in especially in case of D3 because King
goes here and if you try some sort of
Contra attack there is a very important
resource okay E4 you push the Rook back
and then joking D2 and collect the B7
and the B Pawn is much stronger than
Black's Depot
right then we've seen what happened the
way he blonded right I mean it's it's I
I'm not even sure what to say
like he could have taken right yeah
right rookie six I know it was a little
bit earlier later right
where was it check this aha Rook takes
D6 I check on e4 brilliant resource
right and then just take it
and I think it could have been like he
was on seconds and maybe he declined
Queen E6 because of Rook takes D7
because the Rook is hanging right it's
just not realizing he needs a check you
know
okay there's one more uh
one more game that I wanted to Showcase
quickly Rapport was completely winning
against Nepal at some point
uh while he has won a pawn somewhere
around here yeah like move 27 just
captured the pawn on B5 and here white
has everything like a pair of Bishops
you know an extra porn black king being
weak and then what's interesting
practically on every move the engine
that every next move the engine suggests
play G3 win the game play G3 win the
game
he ended up playing G3 and it was still
much better for for Richie and then few
moves later after G4 all he needed to do
is to take on G4
Knight takes Bishop G1 and yeah it's not
winning by itself but like you have
everything under control the king is
safe and so on and so and he aired with
F4 and then after Bishop B2 all of a
sudden there is no way of protecting the
D5 Pawn so the Rooks were traded white
still slightly better but Nepal managed
to save the end game
very very nice uh I you hate I hate that
when you let your opponent off the hook
you have everything under control and ah
standings uh please uh Nazi do the
honors we know our tournament winner
again congrats Magnus but for the second
place
oh absolutely it's quite the contest as
we just in that game that was just
recently played between Magnus and
ferrugia we had some you know magic of
TV and body language of the two players
just towards the end here
yeah I mean as uh they played that very
nervy I mean what you were saying
Perugia up a whole piece but Magnus is
real hard to beat him I
it is a
like if I was sitting I'm trying to
think of Magnus with an extra piece I
would still not be sure at all right I
can win it yeah it's almost like
Frankenstein the monster keeps playing
on and let's jump to Croatia with
Anastasia and Christian
yeah finally somebody who managed to
take him down take the monster down
Magnus that is just an incredible
tournament he's had but I have to say
once again the fight for second position
is hitting up and once again Fabiano had
a great opportunity to take advantage of
the fact that nepo did not lose he was
completely losing he did not lose but he
made a draw so Fabiano with the victory
he would have caught up with nepo
unfortunately for him it did not happen
and in fact he almost lost against Evan
Savage let's take a look at this game
Queen to B3 Rook to C8 Bishop to E2
Fabiano with the white pieces Ivan
sarich with the black pieces and sure
white has a slight Advantage the two
Bishops uh but black has a lot of
compensation for it at some point I will
be able to go if I open up the position
and get to your king and once again this
is a theme that we will be seeing uh in
this game it's King safety and take a
look at this queen to D1 King to F1
white does not want to Castle you cannot
Castle because you're going to lose the
H3 Pawn so you have to keep the Rook on
H1 E5 at the right moment they're nicely
played by uh hd4 and at this point
white is having a tremendous position
because black cannot take on D4 back so
this is just a question because if you
take it you lose your queen yes
you lose everything afterwards of course
and after this maybe one Bishop to F5
because you cannot take your pin down so
this one is completely losing if you
take on a D4 but the plan was always to
try to accommodate uh White on the king
side with the move Queen to D5 and again
it's all about the king's safety at this
point he made a bad move ABIA play the
move F3 it just weakens the king too
much what he had to do was just a simple
King to G1 and this would have kept the
position as is maybe even ideas of
Bishop to F1 and then Bishop to G2
beautiful place for the bishop and after
that it's all she wrote all I have to do
is get the Rook from H1 into play and
this is
so a golden opportunity he played F3 and
this gives black a lot of compensation
to Maya is at this point it's black
who's playing for a victory because the
king is so unsafe on F1 and The Rook on
H1 is not really playing not yet an
important part uh everything is kind of
hanging right so we got into this end
game in which it felt like black has the
upper hand but the position should
remain more or less equal even though
at this particular moment it felt like
white yes
harmonizing species right Consolidated I
want to take on this for as well get a
pawn right I still have some weaknesses
um and this was a critical opportunity
because he could have exchanged the
Rooks with the move Rook to C1 this was
the key moment and black cannot avoid it
you cannot take it because of Knight to
E5 wow that's a nice trick and if you
exchange the Rooks well thank you very
much you cannot touch my pawns anymore
on the king side I will go Knight to D3
I will pick up your pawn and then slowly
I'm going to push you back this is a
very easy technical win and Fabi
wouldn't have risked not winning 61 was
a nice movie you didn't you didn't play
it yes nice movement he played Rook F2
of course again with few seconds on the
clock this is not easy he was even worse
at that point but we don't have that
much time so I want to give you the
opportunity to
um
I would say to the credit of Romania
player he's still fighting in each game
and this one was not an exception you
can check at this moment I like this
move Knight to four if he doesn't then
after you take D5 and actually there is
not a nice place for the night even if
you go to Knight G5 still D4 and what
will you do with your Bishop same goes
before was not just three again before
more so he decided to go back and then
after before he black takes the piece
back nice piece and uh yes nice to be
sacrifice and you can see that black
actually has quite good position
computer actually liked it so we should
decided to take at least this to
Bishop's advantage of the um C8 and
later on I mean they played quite a
balanced game I think Constantine had
some chances even somewhere because his
pieces are more active but at the end of
the day they became finished in the draw
yes but that's the thing Constantine
always seems to be playing very good
open your face he's getting some chances
but then it's all about the time
situation he always falters whenever
they get to their last couple of seconds
exactly yes but he's still fighting yes
in this tournament yeah and I think it's
the last time that my our followers will
see me today in the show and I would
like to remind everyone to follow our
social media accounts uh grantchester
Facebook Instagram and Twitter and thank
you forever thanks for everyone you know
for watching us today and also for my
colleagues it was a pleasure it was a
pleasure to work with you and Associate
we're not picking you out we're just
getting ready for the closing ceremony
and actually the people in St Louis Want
to Say Goodbye as well
Anastasia thank you for everything
from Nasi and I Miro uh thank you for
your social media work uh really great
follow her social media love all your
posts
thank you thank you thank you everyone
and let's let's catch up in the social
media yes
yes right should we talk about
predictions since since
what to do now yes my boy doesn't do
well yes
we picked
yes yes you show understanding this time
next time not like you know what I mean
always
get in let's take a look at the parents
coming up for this penultimate round as
the fight for second is intense and what
a round we have in this terms of this
fight for second Nazi right so on board
one will be a report against Carlton but
the match we're gonna follow closely
will be in the Palm Beach against
Carolina as the destiny is then the
hands of the players then sorry she's
playing good cash Tuda is facing Anand
and look less for against spiritual and
both nepo and Papi are saying to Lupo
lascu okay so it's time for you to make
your uh Victory and as we get ready for
the 17th round once again a big thank
you to our sponsors the Croatia full of
life Foundation thank you very much and
the super United Foundation as well as
the St Louis chess club and Scholastic
Center here in St Louis for all you do
and the World Chess Hall of Fame uh you
folks just make our life so much more
fun and we can do this without our
amazing sponsors so absolutely
and for uh for I want to say the Wild
Card Player Magnus it's getting to be a
habit uh of being the champion and forty
thousand dollars maximum Grand store
points exactly uh taking 13 points in
this podcast Bobby and Christian uh it
probably said you know like I was
rooting for Magnus in Poland to take
first and take the grand Chester points
now uh now he's not rooting so much lots
of Chess still coming your way guess
what upcoming the US Juniors and seniors
Champion for me it's a it's a reunion
but I'll be back for chest nine elex in
September nice nice and chess 9lx of
course is the Bobby Fischer 960. just
hopefully I'll be back as a player for
the U.S women's champion I asked you on
your break what are you doing you said
I'm going to home to study study for the
U.S championships I said well that's not
until October you said yeah but I need
to do a lot of studying yeah yes and
then finishing the year strong with
Saint Louis wrapping and Blitz and of
course single cup Daddy on December 3rd
yeah those are wonderful tournaments and
of course the the St Louis chess club is
hosting the classics as well as we have
our Norm tournaments here at the club uh
so yeah a real summer of Chess non-stop
chess exactly so players getting ready
for this penultimate round uh I have the
feeling that we need
a few players to to go home with a wind
mural I don't know what uh I mean for
Constantine definitely how about even
sarich has he won today but that's what
I'm trying to recall
he did he did have a win okay our
apologies uh we've missed it in this
Magnus Carlson Magnus Carlson just took
all of the oxygen out of their room
right it's all about me
you guys
the white pieces against gukesh getting
ready for again this round 17. but it is
this fight for second that has the
Intrigue NEPA versus Fabi
um give us your Insight first of all who
are you predicting well at the moment
Nepal has a half point lead so nap was
fine even with a draw with the white
pieces I'm gonna guess Snapper's
favorite
sure Catalan
and the players are playing like now
they really are experienced this is the
King's Indian so it's not our game but
this is our game
this is the one we want
and that project
ah D5 takes C4
Bishop D2 very well known there is
thousands of games in this position and
this is what we played all the time that
I win I was a professional player it was
the bishop D2 business that had
everybody's attention Rook A7 that
became
no much later that wasn't a move that
was on we our Focus usually was on the
Move Bishop E4
probably with the help of
easier to know is actually a good move
the engines today have just totally
taken so much of the mystery uh when we
were you know working on our openings
you know everything was questionable you
know was this the right move was that
the what was the precise way of playing
we had really work hard and figure it
out now the engines I like what uh Vichy
says uh I turned on my engine for 24
hours I do a workout and I go oh okay
the idea is good just leave the engine
on for 24 hours it used to take months
and maybe even years to discover
Novelties and try them in the openings
to know if they were good or not but now
it takes yeah 24 hours exactly Bishop E4
Queen D1 uh Fabi said can I grab this
pawn bishop takes F3 Queen takes D4 show
me the compensation and well a2a4 it's
the two Bishops
um well in Catalan whites used to being
down upon yes I always said to Peter
Fiddler that I complained to Peter he
was only happy playing the groomfeld
winning as a pawn down
if Peter wasn't a pawn down he wasn't a
happy camper Rook d8 do your worst
you're welcome to play a B because the
queen is defending the Rook on A7 why
did we put our Rook on A7 well we didn't
blunder the rook and we had it last more
coincidence Bishop E3 so allergic to
retreat alert oh he played 95.
same idea avoiding Bishop E3 and in this
case if you go E2 E4 with the intention
of playing in Bishop E3 then the night
before is an annoying move he's you
don't get to play your eat and you
Bishop to E3
so Knight D5 taking away are we in
theory still or is this or are we in
novel territory I will ask Mira
we were we were up to move A4 they were
following a game from 10 years ago Maya
versus kramnik where big Vlad played C7
C6 Rook d8 is a new move and I'm not
sure if it's the good one at least in
the current position computer turns to
favor white even though whites the pawn
behind uh you win the pawn perhaps right
so you trade on A7
on C7
okay
that's uh and after white gets the pawn
back then why it is preferable because
why isn't it equal well we have a rook
on the seventh rank okay exactly or even
on the either we don't have better
development or anything like that no I
wanted to say uh as you mentioned coming
into this round uh the spin ultimate
round uh nepo is enjoying a half a point
lead so uh certainly the position that
he has on the board right now uh is very
favorable for him from a tournament
standpoint and maybe just the position
itself Knight C3 is on Tap The Rook as
you mentioned already on the seventh
rank
exactly white for choice right and very
low risk for white right
and of course the players are fighting
for the grand chess tour points but cash
as well and there's a nice difference
between second and third five grand
oh so whoa whoa whoa whoa big
does not look happy I think he missed
something you see losing the beat upon
well Rook B7 threatens a back rank mate
and oh so that would be a dead draw but
Napo shaking his head like he just let
something slip away
he might have had something here
maybe he had an advantage earlier that
he
well he he doesn't look happy yeah as if
he just blundered
and the players cannot offer one another
draw but they'll certainly be able to
find a three move threefold repetition
in no time
yeah I guess when he played Bishop B3 he
didn't realize Fabi could play Rook D1
Rook V1 and Bishop F6 and a draw agreed
as nepo maintains his uh half point lead
in second place but I think nepo is
explaining to him you know what I could
have
let's jump to the Magnus Carlson Richie
report game as
interesting it's a board full of pieces
I wanted to say but Bishop takes C5
Richie's eyeballing the D6 Square sorry
this position came from the Sicilian
I I couldn't guess the opening okay I
would have guessed a king's Indian or
maybe a perk but Sicilian no Bishop
takes C5 by the way again a big threat
of Knight D6 check uh so there was no
Queen takes D3 Knight D6 check would
have been uh very very bad news
takes on F5
Rook takes F5 my pawns on D3 and C3 but
I love my knight on D6 yes
the gorgeous piece but it's an extra
Pawn as well right so it's pawn and
position
can Magnus lose two in a row we saw it
in the Rapids
and remember
that in the Rapids that was just a
stunner for Magnus again and let's just
be very clear Magnus is already the
tournament winner and maybe he's let his
guard down a little bit too that's right
yes
you can be capable of losing two games
in a row and then winning nine or you'll
start 11 in a row exactly don't
shortchange our winner
uh Miro jump in uh Richie's looking good
at the moment how good is it uh let me
see well it is pretty good and what I'm
surprised with is yes sir you didn't
really count them pawns I think I did I
did yeah so you figured out quite simple
enough right so right that's the most
information I have yeah okay slightly
better positionally but what's more most
important he's up upon yeah
but but it's also pawn and position
right and I like after 94 I have uh
great pieces and better Center control
with my pawns on C3 D3 my good night on
e4 I'll just defend my pawn and uh
yeah
Magnuson in quite some trouble I would
say at this moment yeah add black
opponent C7 you would still play with
white right exactly exactly take the
yeah take the pawn off of C7 and I'm
more enthusiastic
but there's still a lot of pieces on the
board and we know how tricky magmas can
be truly uh it's a written moment uh H4
H5 starts to be attractive if you play
G5 then Knight H2 Knight G4 that's a
very nice stable Knight if you capture
well that exposes your King by the way
another little crafty move to keep in
mind that Bishop H3 could be uh
disconcerting absolutely Knight H2 with
the idea maybe of H5 and Richard is not
having the best tournament but the fit
in Magnus
that is enough to call a tournament a
success exactly exactly a rook D2 not
only defending but again I think white
uh wants to get on with his business of
playing H5
but he's not Russian he's maneuvering
his pieces improving the position slowly
yes
uh
I like this Knight on G4 somehow this
Knight on G4 just keeping
E3 yes yes
yes and I think King H2 Bishop H3 is yet
again it's also annoying Magnus can't
kick the Knight out because H5 would be
a terrible move given G5 Square for the
other night exactly and that would be a
wonderful Outpost again moves like King
H2 these nice little easy moves that
just tuck things away I liked it both
players now
under one minute yes
three Queen
Queen
C3 that's very nice the reconnected
Pawns in the center
take C3 okay now the the reasons for
playing King H2 are even more compelling
uh as there's a skewer with Bishop H3 to
be had
King age still looks good
everything looks good everything looks
good yeah why this position is just
beautiful at the moment Knight to C3 to
D5 looks good
it looks so pretty I don't even want to
touch it and change it the king H2 I I I
do find it uh confounding how you cannot
play a move like King H2 that is just
such a
with A5 and B5
trying to put some pressure more
pressure on D3
exactly
um
30 seconds for cakes and Knight F2 just
again I'm I'm eyeballing Bishop H3 but
I'm thinking if I can put my Bishop on
e4 Knight on e4 was so pretty I know I
know but sometimes
you know a square is occupied and
another piece would really like that
square in this case the bishop on e4
Magnus allowed the skewer there's Knight
of five though right E4
oh Knight takes G3 I apologize
and Knight takes E2 sure takes E2 oh
pardon me Rook takes E2 yes so it is an
exchange
has won his game
his game we already know that Fabi drew
his game
and Vichy wins with the black pieces
against Duda
wow uh
there she
he's had such a tumultuous event uh so
many had a lot of girls foreign no
Rook to B2 okay finally The Rook decides
to get itself into the game
uh Bishop takes A4 Knight C5 you're
allowing
queen queen H3 whoa what what was so if
we take on A4 Queen G3 on G3 Queen G2 we
take on F2
wait a minute Magnus bluffed Magnus left
there uh Richie should have just I mean
this position looks quite winning as
well but Richie has just had three
seconds on the clock so no way things
three seconds uh Rook B6 Knight E6 on
White's agenda rookette
Rook F7 no I'm not sure oh Knight B3 is
okay eight Rook d8 Rook A8
I'm not happy with Richie's technique
too far
not happy at all
four one again four seconds on the clock
these rings are expected E5 is hanging
D4
yeah a T4 otherwise but now a three E6
okay that's the problem
a37 now looks good E5 and Rook B7 check
yeah I think Russia's got this now
and Rook A3 just to secure that and
maybe the king can come up the board too
that would be nice
keeping the pressure I think he's only
half a point behind Fabiano
exactly
so the last round the second place will
be
despite in this game wow yeah if Magnus
goes down yeah
[Laughter]
would have a significant lead
yeah and Richie is now put the final
final moves together and Magnus goes
down oh boy oh boy do we have any other
games nope they're all done uh fill the
gaps Miro please
won't be able to fill all the gaps and
yeah I'll go with a strange choice of
commentating on the only drone game of
this round right I mean obviously you
can't cover everything but a very
interesting battle between nepo and Fabi
this Rook C1 move a theoretical remember
that it's a brainchild of Vladimir
chronic it turns out he was the one to
play it first with white and then later
on we figured out he was the one
defending with black
it's an interesting idea because you put
some pressure on black if black doesn't
capture on F3 white has quite a pleasant
Advantage so at least this one is
principle caption F3 caption D4 A4 and
as our commentators mentioned during the
game Rook d8 seems to be not the best
move after Queen C2 white was better and
then all good so far
and yeah Queen C7 Queen C7 Rook C7
despite symmetrical nature of the
position white has quite an advantage
Knight D7 and this is why nepo was so
unhappy about this because either E4 or
King F1 King E2 immediately or after E4
would have led to his advantage and
Bishop E3 he thought he is getting
he's getting something Rook D7 and I can
imagine he was
he was waiting for king of Faith after
which Rook B7 is once again a move with
the tempo you're threatening Rook b a
check and then you pick up the B5 pawn
and you are Pawn up in the end game and
he completely missed it after Rook takes
D7
instead of King f8 black has Bishop F6
and that the B2 Pawn is targeted two
times Rook to D7 H7 H6 Rook B5 Rook B5
and that's of course
that's of course at that draw
all right so that was like uh you know a
little a little theoretical a little
theoretical
summary of what has happened right let's
look at the standings for one more time
um yeah I'm happy that nobody picked
Nepal so from the commentators as you
all know we were picking players Magnus
was banned and rightfully so won the
tournament three points lead over nepo
nepo clear second Fabiano caruana third
position still uh fighting for the
second and Ali Reza well we will have to
check the pairings for the last round
Alia Reza might still climb on pedestal
so that will be it and we will be back
for the final round after a short
commercial break
[Music]
it's time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
Young Junior Phenom ABI Manu Mishra and
returning senior Champion Alexander
shavalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move
uni premiere of Chess plays the muni
through July 11 sponsored by St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame for ticketsmuni.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
foreign
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85 000
students in both in school and after
school programs we created the select
chess training program in the junior
select chess training program in order
to elevate the skill level in students
across the St Louis area these students
receive professional training from Grand
Master varusha nicobian other programs
include chess cops a partnership with
the St Louis Police Department looking
to improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 250 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we View chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back we are
in our final round these are our
standings after 17 rounds of Blitz
Magnus Carlson has already won the
tournament but they're still fight for
the second place and it is fierce three
players are fighting for it the only
partnership Fabiano caruana and ferocia
to play for and the pairings for this
our final round 18. cross finish playing
with
we will have to use that as our Marquee
matchup and Carolina Rapport will be our
Rebecca absolutely absolutely has
Constantine saved his best for last well
we were about to find out as this is the
18th round and boy I feel it now I feel
like uh there was an adrenaline rush but
I'm almost like a Magnus you know
feeling the ebb and flow of the
excitement of of having won the
tournament already but we're Mira we're
on our final shoes over here how about
yourself oh well yeah final round highly
anticipated you know uh guys I was able
to extract a little bit more information
from the standings because I want to
mention that Fabiano Carona is currently
leading the GCT believe it or not so it
doesn't matter the last round he will
overtake the current leader Wesley saw
who is not present here right so he will
get some points and this some points
added to Fabiano's victory in Bucharest
will be enough for him to lead GCT
standings as after this tournament oh
absolutely no question about that and
here are the GCT standings Wesley so was
leading until today and young christop
to do that in the second place but both
Duda and Fabiano will be getting more
points after today and probably sharing
first and second and Wesley moving back
to third place shockingly enough you see
Ian Yan at the bottom there with only
two points from the Bucharest event even
though he will probably gain maybe as
many as 10 points if you were to take
clear second here it would avoid that
that horrible combination of Bucharest
and Zagreb let's not forget Richard he's
not doing so badly either not at all I'm
sure this last round would be very
important for his GCT point standings
can you believe we're in the last round
yeah we've we've experienced so much
we've been on this roller coaster ride
along with Magnus Carlson again this
staggering Sensational result of winning
11 games in a row nine Blitz in a row
yesterday just one day
uh but then he came in and uh well I
think he had a decent performance but as
you were mentioning back-to-back losses
yes last two rounds did not go his way
and I'm sure he's not happy about it no
not at all that game with Perugia by the
way he was that close to getting the
2900 rating uh
keeps his number one number one spot yes
he does
uh spoiler indeed as their EC Ali Reza
our defending grantchester Champion by
the way he once put himself in a
position that when the tour does come to
St Louis that still has a chance to win
absolutely absolutely go cash a 17 year
old Vietnam
acquitted himself nicely I want to say
in this Grand Chester showing that he's
going to be a future tour participant no
pleasure his first
getting investing Vichy in the rapid
that was really a big result and then
once in the Blitz in the blitz as well
that was really really nice
uh trying to sum up some of the
Sensational things that we've witnessed
over the course of the five days mirror
what stood out for you especially now
well magnus's result of course right and
yeah well one I still well I'm honestly
rooting for Constantine in this last
round I don't want to upset Magnus but
man to play in such a tournament and do
not win a single game that's that's hurt
that's painful yes
yes as uh Jan returns to his roots uh
grunfeld Greenfield in the last round I
remember the world championship matches
of Kasparov and karpov with the Knight
E5
uh lines that became very very
theoretical
so here there's of course Knight C6
moved also 94 if I remember yes 95 and
you go
yes I send the database Nepal has played
this before with black pieces this exact
position
oh that's such a drawish line
Bishop A3 Queen A6 and we are back to
symmetry right oh wow it is
foreign
[Laughter]
but for nepo a draw means that uh the
worst case uh he probably he'll be
sharing second exactly should we switch
to Fabius games sure this game is very
drawish exactly somehow you know when
when uh Fabio is going to cross swords
with Richie report the game's not going
to be a boring one as uh we do have
Kings India kings Indian on the board
but I think we're out of theory at this
point
cleaning the bishop pardon me the bishop
hits the Knight the Knight drops back
Knight to C4
hitting this Pawn
the things
I'm gonna say queen G6 I hate walking
into those pins those Queen E7 it's only
temporary you could play H6
it might be his own Bishop H4 I don't
know but I I prefer Queen G6 in in any
case uh
if I have to defend the pawn on D6 by
moving my knight I would my queen feels
better on G6 now the question is F4
right
looks like black is doing great in this
opening well is yeah it's a
is these Kings Indians you know you're
gonna get your play
what does engine tell us is black
already better uh yeah it tells that
Bishop E3 was a terrible oversight he
had to play other Queen D2 or Bishop H4
and Bishop E3 was kind of asking for a
foreign it was played and well with all
the ideas like Knight jumping to before
you know going to C2 right on Bishop F4
black has Knight E4 white king stuck in
the center not canceled it's very very
bad in fact yeah Queen G2 on Black's
agenda oh my goodness uh by the way that
Bishop on G7 lurking uh nicely before
coming in Bishop before yeah hello hello
night uh C2
on tap by the way D5 Pawn is hanging a
lot of things have gone wrong suddenly
for white so I might collapse very
quickly in this position
yeah everything's open queenside the
king's side the center uh
yes yes uh King F1 side steps Knight C2
and it does set up for Rook G1 but
excuse me Bishop takes H3 so how am I
meeting Knight C2 oh Bishop to D3 that's
the idea thank you because otherwise it
would be really really bad but hold on
Knight C2 Bishop is Phi F3 which Richard
just did and then go Knight C2 ah
much better and F3 is a good sacrifice
anyways opening up their file exactly
yes no that Rook on f8 lurking and
Ambush as well
um
First Impressions is this game has gone
terribly terribly wrong and it might
just be over before start started night
takes good before Nepal he would
guarantee himself clear second place so
Knight takes D4 Queen takes D4 where's
my beautiful tempo
uh Knight
D7 to E5
or H5
Knight to H5 to G3
or okay so I'm starting with Knight D4
right
uh he played Bishop F5
oh hello Bishops
it's not deadly maybe because I can
cover with Bishop E2 right I I was I was
thinking Bishop D3 stops the defense of
the bishop on D4 sight but you're right
Bishop to d three check Bishop E2
doesn't cost material but I can't find
I really want to play Rook G1 but
there's Bishop H3 so Knight takes D6
I'll take the pawn
when you don't
right Knight E2
uh good night E2 so now 94 Knight takes
Bishop D3 Bishop B2 there has to be some
tactic Queen E4 maybe this should
the degree sorry and then on Bishop you
took Queen E4
Bishop D3 immediately Rook G1 there was
no Bishop takes H3 that was very
fortuitous for
fobby that he could get in the move Rook
G1
but wait a minute so now he's got F3 is
hanging D4 is hanging there's so many
pieces next to each other right it's
very difficult to calculate so which
pieces are hanging
uh this guy and this guy two Bishops can
I take
no
I'm thinking it might be time to bail
out with something like Rook takes and
Bishop to G4 besides the two Bishop
singing There's Pawn on H3 hanging
six I think
hanging right
it's just hard to count Miro can you
help us out
well all the things yeah that's a that's
a crazy position guys Bishop takes F6
has been placed Bishop F6 as a mistake
black is winning yeah the let's postpone
it till after the game is over okay just
too much so right now black is winning
with F6
rip takes F6 sets up a queen takes F2
mate so Rook G3 would be the only
defense Rook to G3 but that will allow
94.
looks very strong doesn't it Knight D4
both night on E2 and Bishop on F3 are
pinned right it's just amazing that
somehow you know you're not winning
material with Bishop takes C4 but yes
Knight D4
looks very attractive Rook f8 what do
you think of Rook f8 by the way
I mean it doesn't it because you might
be threatening Queen takes D3 in that
case Rook f8 just bringing the last
resource into play
to go Bishop
before but then I
then I wait
is there a question Bishop E2 Queen E2
Knight D4 Knight D4 right away uh Rook C
you know when you're on the attack one
of the things I like to advise is when
you're on the attack make sure you
invite everybody to the party uh Rook A8
to f8 to my mind is you know like
perfect for the position Knight D4 also
looks like a very nice move as you're oh
now just Bishop E2 right because you
can't take with the bishop
and Magnus has won the final game
finishing with a win once again our
congratulations to Magnus for winning
the tournament he did it uh with quite a
number of rounds to spare already and in
this position Fabi as to cough up
material he took on The Rook took on G7
King takes G7 Knight takes F5 Rook takes
F5 will just be in exchange for a pawn
but it's a terrible Bishop terrible and
black should be completely winning yeah
really winning uh nepo shall we go back
to nepo's game uh against gukesh has
anything happened
a lot has happened there in the pawn
ending oh really okay well
I can draw
right King D6 oh King B5
yeah sorry I'm just I know it sounded
like crickets there for a second but uh
who who was better why is this
is anyone better
No it should be a joke I can play King
D3 King D5
Kings history King E5
are you faster no it is testing
we're seeing you to calculate at a very
early uh hour here in St Louis
let's maybe look at ferocious game
because he yeah it um past Fabi since
fabi's going down in firusha if he wins
yep which is
third he's on board four board four
alireza is what against Duda
upon
but his Knight on A2 absolutely awful
awful in the night on C5 is a monstrous
night just really really uh
in all of its Glory there
but uh clock times
um or four seconds for Duda oops 45 for
ferrugia so that's going to be an issue
for sure and oopsie Daisy and there's
last trades of Rook has made room for
the night on A2 to get back into the
game finally coming back some maybe the
extra Pawn will actually have an impact
absolutely well Knight D3 you don't want
to allow
Bishop takes C1
three nice Blockhead on black squares
with the bishop
remember I mean that was a huge
accomplishment to get rid of that Knight
on C5
so farouja is definitely it's a two
result game now
by the way draw yeah end game ended in a
draw is predict
and um Queen deed now absolutely Queen
d8 isn't don't really need to calculate
because you know it it should be
whatever it should be winning exactly
Queen d8 trade Queens Knight can come to
B7 and he's done it then F4 King F3
bring the king and should for Rouge help
me out once again even though we've
we've shown the standings each and every
time
um it's it's so close at the very top
so Richard did won his game did win his
game against Fabiano right now can
ferrugia tie nepo though
if you're Russia wins either he ties or
he passes Fabiano that's right he passes
Fabiano but I think no it's as secured
his second place yes and C4 C5
right
C5 we have Knight E5 check
Knight E5 no 95 is beautiful I know
isn't it nice 95. very nice takes and
King F2 and that should be a winning
King upon
yep and there's E3
beautiful and the handshake as far Asia
well stormed back at the very end he
just one game still going on it's Vichy
against Ivan sarage we have a queen
ending Yvonne is up up a pawn but it
looks like fishy has a Perpetual check
right
well I think it's fitting that the local
uh play uh corrosion
and for Rouge it does as you mentioned
surpass Fabi at the pipped at the Finish
there that 18th round game was one round
too many for Fabi as Fabi drops to
Fourth Perugia jumps to Third
wow uh Miro uh try to sum up uh this
round five day five of The Blitz uh well
the games are still like very very
impressive but you know perhaps a bit of
fatigue takes its toll because quite a
lot of games then you know one side
plays close to perfect and then lets it
sleep at the very end
and yeah so by the way that was the case
in the game that you were looking at uh
farby against Rapport because report on
a couple of occasions given fubby
chances to you know to get away but they
were not taken
so just quickly I believe that was the
you know the best game of the last round
so let's just quickly watch this one
again uh the king's Indian
all there was seen and I think I'll
start with this yes Knight C4 and even
though computer claims that Queen D7 is
playable no we don't play king's Indian
for that Queen G6 of course Bishop E3 as
I've mentioned was
quite a big mistake so F4 takes takes
Bishop D4 but this is where things
starting to get interesting right night
before we all know that yes black must
be winning but it's Blitz you don't have
the time to calculate so basically you
play moves with your hands yeah with
your feeling you know how to uh how to
play The King's Indian and there was one
moment yes after F3 black is winning
there was one really really funny moment
this queen F5 wasn't the best so what he
I know apparent yeah Bishop D3 wasn't
the best he should have gone Knight to
D4 right yeah sorry we don't have the
time to look at this update it's a
beautiful game so that just advised to
look at it at home let's take a look at
our final standings of Zagreb 2023 and
here it goes the Wild Card of the
tournament Magnus Crossing wins the
tournament and forty thousand dollars
surprising for part for me is our second
wild card also in the top five they're
congratulations to good cash on his Fine
Results his player finish in fifth but
Yanni polish actually had a wonderful
tournament got overshadowed by Magnus
but congrats on the second place no
question about it 10 GCT points yawn
bouncing back from the horrible showing
in Bucharest and for Russia after a
couple days of struggle in the rapid
came back in the Blitz and finished
third very solid performance congrats
and we see the the results of Route 18
costing Fabiano five thousand dollars
there and let's jump to Croatia for our
closing ceremonies
thanks yaser after five days of exciting
chess we are finally ready to Crown a
champion we are a joint bar Marine Mar
usage who is the CEO of super United
Croatia as well as Michael kodarkovski
the executive director of the grand
Chester and of course our champion
Magnus Carlson Michael I'm going to give
you the first word
yes thank you Chris it is excitement uh
here in Zagreb this is our last uh tour
in Europe third leg and we would like to
congratulate Magnus Carlson uh number
one player in the world who actually
made hat trick here in Zagreb this year
this is the third win since 2019 in
Zagreb and once again Magnus Carlson
showed Excellency and Supremacy in these
tournament so I would like again to
congratulate him and thanks our sponsors
super United Saint Louis chess club and
I would like to pass microphone to CEO
of super United Marine marush
thank you very much Michael
um I'm glad that I can welcome all the
all the players in Zagreb all the GCT
tour it's very nice to see you again
it's very nice that I will present the
second time in a row for me I haven't
had a chance to have a hat-trick but
hopefully I will have a hat-trick next
year so it's nice to present another
trophy to Mr Magnus congratulations I
know that you're a big fan of Croatia
I'm very happy for that thanks for uh
for all the nice pictures and photos and
thanks for promoting Croatia such a
beautiful country for a great holiday
and thanks for promoting chess and
helping to all the kids who are playing
chess because of you and all this good
chess players here with us thank you
very much
Magnus back-to-back victories in the
grand chest tour how are you feeling
right now uh I'm completely spent uh
I've had no energy to to to play today I
felt you know uh
yesterday was
such a great day and I felt today that
I didn't have much to to give so I was
really just trying to get over the
finish line but I'm really happy that I
uh that I did uh and um
yeah feels always feels great to win
you've said it after the rapid portion
uh that your opponents will need to have
a great tournament in order to stop you
from winning the Bliss portion what gave
you that confidence
well I I thought that if I had like
a normal to good event it would be would
be tough and I think alireza scored
about this expected
um I think he made 13 points if I'm not
mistaken yeah which is really really
good plus eight uh but and um also
Jan and Fabi performed fairly normally
and I had my best best Blitz result ever
in the grand Chester and that's
obviously why it was not close tell us
about uh that the historical day one
might say you scored nine out of nine if
you count the uh two rapid games 11 out
of 11 what did that mean for you
yeah it was
it was a was a fun day
um I can say that um
it felt very very special
um and uh
you know there are there are days when
um
yeah they're they're ideas that are just
better than the others I would say that
um I love playing playing chess uh
and
I
I mean there are tournaments that I can
still sort of win but
to be honest like that achievement feels
feels sweeter than than almost any
tournaments tournament win because it's
it's something I've never done before
and we'll do again it's definitely a
performance that left the Chess World
the speechless congratulations uh Magnus
you are the champion of the 2023 super
United rap templates thank you so much
for the last time back to you guys in St
Louis
thank you Christian once again our great
congratulations to Magnus and what a
performance on day four one for the
history books absolutely it was a
privileged to watch truly and it's nice
to see uh Magnus struggling to find the
words as we commentators did as well as
the GCT tour finishes its European legs
and there we have our standings now with
three events included yes well we can
still take notice that some players have
played three events some still only have
played two it's so Fabiano caruana now
live in the grandchild store with 20 jcd
points and young Christopher in the
second place with 18. Richard Rapport
and alireza firosha third and fourth
exactly as those players with two events
played will be playing in the St Louis
rapid and Blitz as well as the sync
build cup and other players who have
played three events will only be playing
in the single cup and not at the St
Louis Rapids
Miro uh bring it all together sum it all
up if you will my friend uh well what
can I say it's a historical event and
yeah once again congrats Magnus
and thanks very much guys for having me
on the team enjoyed it immensely and
will be happy in the future
absolutely thank You Nero and I want to
say thank you so very much Nasi really
uh these five days have been really
great your hands are cold by the way
but if I really I've enjoyed uh working
with you and Mara so very very much and
our all of our production team here
likewise it was a pleasure uh thank you
yes sir and Miro for creating such a fun
atmosphere absolutely and to our
production team once again thank you for
all you do thank you to St Louis and we
will be seeing you for the juniors the
girls and the senior championships
coming up in just as
four or five days time we'll see you all
then thank you thank you for sharing
your days with us goodbye for now thank
you
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited